This is Jocko podcast number 75 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo.
Good evening.
We have shared the incommunicable experience of war.
We have felt we still feel the passion of life to its top
in our youth.
Our hearts were touched by fire.
That's a quote from Oliver Wendell Holmes Supreme Court judge.
Lots of people know that,
but they may not know.
Civil War soldier served with the 20th Regiment of Massachusetts,
volunteer infantry
saw action all over the place.
Peninsula campaign,
the wilderness.
He was wounded at the battle of balls bluff,
also wounded and Antietam and also wounded at the battle of Chancellorville.
So I think it's safe to say that he knew and understood war.
And that quote right there is from the beginning of another book about another
man that new war,
Major Dick Winters.
Now we've covered Dick winters before his book on this podcast.
Number 17 beyond band of brothers.
Great Book,
lots of lessons learned,
but there's another book which is called the conversations with major dick
winters life lessons from the commander of the band of brothers.
And it's written by a guy named Colonel Cole c King seat,
who was a friend,
Dick Winters,
and who actually was the coauthor behind that book,
beyond band of brothers.
So what's cool about this book is it really parses out some lessons about
leadership in a conversational manner with Dick winters.
The things that he thought and the lessons that he learned,
which I mean,
when you get an opportunity to learn for someone like this,
you know what I do?
I just be quiet.
I listened and I learned.
Or in this case I read and I learned.
So this is also the guy,
if you haven't seen this series on Hbo,
Band of brothers,
just go stop and just go watch it.
It's,
I dunno what it is,
like 12 suit,
12 episodes.
They're all awesome.
Everybody asks me all the time,
what's realistic war movies that one band of brothers and then the Pacific,
all both HBO series,
they're both phenomenal.
And I recommend you watch,
you'll learn a lot about dick winters on that.
And the,
and the guy that plays Dick winters does a great job.
And the way they tell the story and the realism and all that.
It's just an awesome series.
But here we can learn,
not interpreted through a movie but actually from the man as he spoke it.
So here we go.
Taking it to the book right now
from Dick Winters
d day was my first time in combat.
So right there.
Let's just talk about that for a second.
Your first time in combat,
what's your mission?
The day
one of the largest military operations of all time.
That's your first day in combat.
Get some
back to the book.
I was mentally prepared and felt that I had done everything necessary to prepare
myself for this precise moment and you never know if you will measure up as a
leader until the minute arrives.
When you face the enemy for the first time,
baptism by fire as a soldier sacrament,
there was always doubt.
Hopefully in combat you perform as you train.
So I can't imagine that baptism by fire d day again get get some sense of
another good movie saving private Ryan.
The opening scene of that is the same thing.
And
that's,
that's one of the most intense parts of a movie ever is the d day when they're
hitting the beaches.
It's crazy to watch but watch it.
Cause it'll give you a feeling for what Dick winters is talking about.
And just imagine all these preparation that you do.
You're getting ready.
And guess what?
Here it comes.
Little mission called D Day.
Now they all they have,
that was their initial operation was during the day,
but then they fought all over the place.
And again,
we cover this and in beyond band of brothers,
but one of the most intense parts of their campaign was at Bastogne.
So even though d day was hard,
things didn't get easier once dd was completed,
as much as I'm saying,
Oh yeah,
d day was crazy.
Guess what?
It wasn't even the hardest part for them.
Things got worse back to the book.
Most of the soldiers and easy company also felt that Bastogne was the most
challenging month of the war.
Staff Sergeant Bill Guan near later claimed that he had been scared before,
but he was absolutely petrified at Bastogne.
From my perspective,
Bastogne was the most miserable place I've been in my life.
I was wet through and through and naturally being a paratrooper.
I didn't have a change of clothes,
no blanket,
nothing,
and it was a cold son of a gun.
Things were all snafued walking around in the black of night,
not knowing where we were,
exactly where everybody else was.
Houses,
burning civilians,
crying,
wringing your hands and behind every Bush a a perspective enemy.
We took our greatest number of casualties during that campaign.
Easy company was never the same after Bastogne we lost so many because we lost
so many veterans who had fought in Normandy and Holland,
Joe Toy Bill Gorn,
Air Buck Compton,
dawn who blur and many others.
So this is,
this is where I started thinking,
okay,
leadership lesson learned right here.
I operated the battalion command post that was situated approximately 75 yards
from the main line of resistance.
You might not think 75 yards.
It's consequential,
but it gave me the opportunity to think things through and divorce myself from
the chaos surrounding the front line and to make calm,
rational decisions under pressure.
That is the toughest challenge for any leader.
So obviously we're talking about detachment here,
and I've talked about the fact that in order to detach,
you can move off the line like six inches.
I'm not kidding.
In a smaller group,
you know when a single platoon,
he's talking about a battalion,
so they've got hundreds of guys,
so 75 yards is more appropriate.
But if you're running a smaller unit,
like one company or maybe a platoon,
you got 30 40 guys.
If you move back off that firing line,
six inches,
a foot maybe,
you know,
maybe three feet or six feet,
you just step back and you get yourself out of that firefight where you can look
around.
That's what you're going to be able to do.
You're going to be able to detach yourself from the chaos and the mayhem and
make calm,
rational decisions under pressure.
And that's such a big deal.
Like we're,
when you do that,
when you detach and then you can,
you know,
you have a clear vision and a lot of times the answer or a solution to some big
problem is just so simple.
Remember that story you were telling it,
the muster where,
you know your,
your guys had an injured neck so he couldn't participate but you wanted to come
along until you watch them from the outside.
And he's like,
why don't they just step back and peel left?
Or why don't they,
why don't they get online and peel whatever the call was.
So the story is there was a guy that actually,
he was the Delta platoon commander,
Ntu Bruser.
He took over my position,
he took over as the t you bruiser commander and then I was running the training.
So once I was running the training,
you know,
now I was overall making things happen and he was going through the training,
a different block of training and he broke his neck,
broke his neck and thank God he didn't hurt his spinal cord,
but he broke vertebrae in his neck.
So we had to wear one of those big crazy neck braces and he couldn't actually do
the physical training.
It wasn't allowed to bear any weight for a certain amount of time.
But you know,
luckily he was able to keep his,
his job because he was very experienced.
And so we were going through the land warfare portion of training and I said,
hey man,
you know,
I know you can't participate but come out with me,
come out and check it out and you know,
you can see your guys and you can watch how they perform and you can,
you know,
teach them some stuff and learn from,
from what happens.
So cool.
He comes out and he's actually one of my,
one of my best friends.
So of course we just wouldn't hang out anyways.
So,
you know,
of course he has a chance to come out and hang out with me.
The desert for a few weeks is going to do it.
So we,
we get out there and,
and you know,
you've heard the stories about the training that I ran.
It was really hard and evil and crazy and psychotic.
And we're doing that.
You know,
we got,
we,
in that case,
we had these really high speed laser,
laser tag system and you've got guys pin down,
you got explosions going off,
you've got just total mayhem going on in.
His guys kind of froze up and they're all pinned down in this little sorta
ravine valley type thing.
And I got guys,
I got my guys,
my opposing force,
so the seals that are pretending to be bad guys pretending to be moved,
they're all up in the mountains shooting down on them and killing everyone and
his guys,
his leadership is just kind of frozen and they're sitting there and not do
anything.
And you know,
he says to me,
hey,
can I help them?
And I,
I kind of thought about it from it.
I go,
yeah,
go ahead.
I go give him,
you know,
tell him what to do,
give him a prompt.
And He,
and he just,
you know,
goes down to the leader,
one of the leaders and says,
hey,
get online and peel left.
And so the guy looks at him.
And what does get online?
I mean it's an organizational movement where all your troops are pointed in all
different directions.
Yeah,
boom.
You'd say contact right online.
And that means everyone's going to basically facing that direction who get a
couple guys that are doing risk security.
A couple of guys that are doing flexicurity but everyone is now oriented in the
same direction.
And then the next call that comes is PLF boom.
And they're all going to start moving in a direction that's going to get them
out of this immediate threat.
So he tells,
he kinda says the guy,
hey,
get online,
peel left.
So the guy looks at him and he just yells out,
get online,
peel left,
and then everyone repeats that command and then everyone does it.
And within a minute they're there.
Homefree it literally took like one minute once I made the decision.
Yeah.
So and then so,
so they get out of there and he looks at me and he goes,
he goes,
pan,
it's so easy when you're way up here.
Now way up here to put it in perspective was four feet behind these guys.
That's all it was.
It wasn't like we were up on some mountain top with some incredible,
if,
you know,
we were,
we were there,
we were standing next to the guys and we are a little bit elevated cause they're
laying down and we're standing up.
But it's not inconceivable that you wouldn't have the same perspective if you
just step back and maybe,
you know,
shuffled over a little bit.
And he says,
it's so easy when,
when you're up here.
And I said,
Bro,
you remember when we went through training?
And he says,
yeah.
And I said,
it was always like this for me.
And it was,
I was,
I would always just put myself back just enough to be able to see what the is.
Yeah.
So yes,
this detachment that he's talking about,
and again,
in a battalion situation where you're going 75 yards and 10 in a business
situation,
you know,
I actually see people do this.
You're in a,
you're in a meeting and there's everyone around them around the table.
And there's some problem that can't be solved.
Literally step up and step away from the table and just step back.
Get away from the group because they're all mobbed up in group.
Think everyone's going down the same trail.
They're thinking about the same stuff and there's no new ideas because they're
all right there in this vortex.
Step away from the table.
Yeah.
It's same thing like step,
step away from your computer.
Yeah.
You get to some point where you're just,
you don't know where to go with some,
you're looking for some kind of a solution to a problem.
Just step back,
step back,
see more.
Yeah.
And writing.
A lot of times they'll suggest just skip to the end.
Don't worry about this.
Just go to the ant.
How do you want it to end?
And then it'll kind of open your mind up.
It'll,
it'll make you sort of forget about this problem right in front of you,
you know?
Yeah.
I can give you kind of an overall view of move you towards the solution that you
know can be found.
Yeah.
Even in an argument with you wife or something like that?
Oh yeah.
Well for sure.
That's a big one for sure.
Cause when you,
yeah,
you definitely need to do it.
They're entrenched.
You don't need to get entrenched.
Don't do that.
All right,
and this part's been covered before on multiple occasions.
You know what we're gonna do.
Cover it again,
little piece about discipline.
I did have a routine,
a routine that was instilled into me by Colonel Sync at Koa.
Colonel Sink insisted that officer's always shave in the morning regardless of
the situation.
He would say you shave every morning for the troops and if you want to shave
every evening for the women,
that's up to you.
I followed his orders because I realized that I had to set the proper example
for the men I needed to get their attention and let them all know that I
intended to be around for awhile and that the situation was not as bad as they
might think.
I remembered before second battalion attacked Foy.
I had awakened early and shaved before I ate breakfast.
I later discovered that I had cut my face in multiple places.
I'm Colonel Sink,
came up to check on the battalion's readiness before the attack commenced.
He took one look at me and smiled.
I realized that he was laughing at me for shaving on that bitterly cold morning.
In hindsight,
shaving a zero dark 30 and freezing temperatures was pretty ridiculous.
So you know when we talk about this all time,
got to shave,
got to maintain unmitigated daily discipline in all things.
But what's cool,
but what I,
the reason I wanted to go over this again is because look at what he's doing
psychologically to the troops.
He saying,
I know I had to set an example.
I needed to get their attention and make them realize like,
hey,
we're going to here for awhile and you know what?
I'm just going to go daily.
This is no big deal.
Oh,
you're worried about this stuff.
I'm still shaving over here.
I'm still waking up at zero 400 shaving and,
and you're worried about this stuff.
Nothing to worry about.
We're good to go.
And you need to maintain the same discipline.
So that leading by example clearly is a big deal right there and maintaining
that routine,
maintaining that discipline.
Now,
speaking of discipline back to the book,
regardless of how disciplined and outfit is,
too much time on your hands,
too little activity and too much alcohol,
make a vol tile combination.
So this book skips around a little bit,
but I put this in here because this is,
this is actually talking about when they were done fighting and now everyone was
kind of idol.
He has some idle people on their hands,
but it related to discipline.
So I wanted to lock it in a little bit.
Back to the book.
The battalion was no longer a combat unit,
but a garrison outfit.
It was more important to keep the troops gainfully employed to prevent boredom
and monotony.
That would lead to a breakdown in discipline.
And when that occurs,
soldiers get careless.
Consequently,
the first thing we organized,
we're calisthenics and athletic programs.
You know,
I always joke about,
you know,
when people say they have some kind of problem and I'm,
Oh,
do burpees,
hey,
you know what a good solution to all problems are.
Calisthenics,
just start doing calisthenics.
I liked that.
I liked that attitude.
I vividly recall this is,
this is another reason why I put this in.
I vividly recall watching the men's strip to their waist or only wearing their
shorts as they played baseball.
The sight of all those scars made me conscious of the fact that only a handful
of men in the battalion had been lucky enough to make it through all four
campaigns without at least one scar.
Some men had two,
three or even four scars on their chest,
back,
arms or legs.
Keep in mind that this was after the war,
so I was looking only at men who will not seriously wounded.
Next,
we set up rifle ranges and sharpened our marksmanship,
close order drill and troop reviews.
We're once again back on the training schedule.
I also established a schedule where each of our four platoons could rotate every
72 hours to a ski lodge in the Alps for rest and relaxation.
The purpose of using this retreat was to let them and get away from the routine
of a military schedule.
So first of all,
when,
when I got to seal team one,
and actually it was,
it wasn't what I,
when I first got there,
but there was a master chief at seal team one that had showed up in 1971 or 1972
to seal team one and CLT in one.
You know,
you had 150 guys are roughly on the team at that time.
And they had had 34 killed in action in Vietnam at seal team one and wounded
was,
I don't know how many wounded,
but it was a lot.
But this,
this guy who was a master chief when I met him and he was telling me that when
he,
you know,
at the seal team you would,
you PT in the morning,
just like a sports team,
you get,
you get to work and you work out and here's the,
he's a new guy,
right?
And he's,
they PT and then they go in the shower,
you know,
to,
to wash off.
And it's the same thing.
He's like looking at every single guys scarred up,
wounded,
you know,
slashes on their chest.
Bullet holes in him.
And he kind of was saying to himself,
damn,
you know,
this is a,
this has been trial by fire for these guys.
But beyond that,
what he's talking about here clearly is,
if you,
and I'll tell you this,
especially with,
you know,
18 year old,
19 year old,
20 year old males that have joined the military,
if you don't find something for them to do productive,
they're going to find something to do that's not going to be productive and
it'll be fun for him.
It'll be fun formed are gonna have a good time,
but it's not,
there's a chance that they could be doing something better than what you're
letting them do.
Now,
of course,
he talks about the fact that he's given him,
still giving them time to go out to the ski lodge and,
and break away from it a little bit.
But you just gotta be careful in how you do that.
You gotta be careful in how you do that.
It's,
it can backfire if you're not careful.
And the first time I was ever kind of detached from a seal platoon on a a was
when I went to training the training department at [inaudible],
what we used to call it training cell,
which sounds legit and it wasn't a gin.
So at training cell,
the first trip I went on with a platoon,
because I was always in the platoon.
So the first trip I went on with the platoon and I was outside of the platoon
and I was you,
you could say I was an instructor even though we weren't running around calling
ourselves instructor instructors,
we would call ourselves actually the cadre,
I don't know why,
it's just like,
Oh yeah,
cadre sound's still is an official term.
Yeah.
Kadri the training cadre.
So when we were at training cell,
because the instructors are kind of considered the buds instructors,
the guys are the basic training and,
and we didn't really want to be buds instructors.
We were the contract.
So,
and I'd never,
I didn't mean this is just,
this is just my own assessment.
I didn't pick up Kadra Eddie can call ourselves Godrej didn't make up training
sale.
I wish I would've made up all those things,
but I just flowed into him as a lucky young new guy.
Or actually at this point I wasn't a new guy anymore.
But it's true though.
Right?
It's not like you just gave yourself a title that will,
no,
we're the car.
Yeah.
Oh,
training cadre.
Yeah.
Oh,
hey,
I need to talk to the guys in the contrary over here.
Yeah,
that's what,
that's what we called ourselves.
Well,
yeah,
so it's like,
you know,
like with the,
you open it,
you get to the gym and then you know,
you're teaching people and then you're like,
okay,
yeah,
I'm the instructor.
And then you think,
you know what,
I like professor.
That's better.
No,
it wasn't that I didn't make that.
no,
no.
They called,
you know,
for years.
And actually I think Roger Hayden talked about it when,
when he was on the podcast he was talking about when he was contrary,
so,
right.
It's been around forever.
Right.
That's why I just like professor,
it's like,
it's true you are the professor,
but it's like,
it just sounds,
it's just better.
You know,
it sounds better.
You want,
go ahead and go with that one and just go with contrary.
Yeah.
I like Nah,
don't even know what I was talking about.
Oh,
so I was,
I was in the contract for the first time and we went on a trip and went to a
trip where they have good times to be had where we were.
It was a,
it was a place where there's some good training,
but there's also good times.
And you picked us up from Harley Flanagan,
this term bridge.
I hadn't really heard wilding.
Did you ever hear him say that?
He's like,
oh we were just wilding,
which I think is a better term than the term that we discussed,
which was partying.
Right?
Oh there's good.
Yeah,
we were partying.
I like wild and better cause that entails all kinds of other things that'll be a
little bit more wild wilding out or once they see a while,
and I never really heard of him.
I'd never really heard it before,
but when Holly sent me clearly know what it is.
Yeah.
And it's in his book too.
He talks about wilding.
So we went to this place with a seal platoon where there was good training and
good wilding to be had.
And I remember the first time that these guys,
you know,
we get there,
we work a little bit and then they're going to go out into the town.
And I remember thinking myself,
they'd been in the field for a few days and they were all fired up young frogman
and I was thinking myself,
how is this even gonna work?
Like there's no,
there's no possibility of this going well.
And it did.
You know everyone fine,
but you just see all these guys,
they're ready.
Do you know they're ready to explode and you're going to,
they've been in the field,
they have dehydrated,
they'd been in the field for four days or five days.
They're all dehydrated and they completed their operation.
They feel good about it and now you're going to let them out in town.
Yeah,
you gotta be careful in those scenarios.
You got to put something we would,
you know,
sometimes you just say,
hey,
look God,
do whatever you want tonight.
But where P team tomorrow at zero 700 so then everyone knows they can,
they can wild to a point,
but they can't.
They got to put some kind of a governor,
some kind of a governor on the scenario.
And here's a cool piece where Dick winters,
you know,
he talks about it,
I've talked about this before,
but
just,
just a piece about his view of what America was doing at the time.
Back to the book of the United States went to war,
not to conquer territory or to subject their fellow man,
but merely to liberate a conquered people from the chains if tyranny there is a
certain nobility and all that.
Today we are bombarded in the news media about how everyone hates America and
how this country is deployed around the world.
World War II wasn't like that.
And I am proud to be a part of it.
So again,
I've said this a bunch of times,
you know,
we went there and lost hundreds of thousands of people in Europe and in and in
the Pacific theater
and we took nothing.
Hmm.
We only gave
some thoughts on leadership from Dick Winters,
leadership.
Leadership's defining quality is honesty to honesty and fairness and
consistency.
I was able to develop a sixth sense during the war that allowed me to size up a
situation rapidly.
I could look at terrain and be able to see opportunities instead of challenges
by leading from the front.
I believe I achieved a high degree of success.
So I thought that was a very,
very interesting combination.
Honesty,
fairness and consistency.
You don't hear those a lot about being a great leader.
I mean,
I always talk about the number one attribute of a leaders is humility and I
definitely believe that humility is important,
but honesty,
that's clearly
a thought and a concept of leadership that I'd think that misses a lot of
people.
I think,
and we've talked about plenty of cases on the podcast here where we say,
oh,
what if this is going on?
And I say,
look,
do you want to be honest with them?
You know,
so I've definitely said that before,
but I'm going to start saying it more because I'm learning a little something
from Dick winters today.
But you know,
I remember we had a case where someone was saying,
Hey,
I'm going to leave this job.
I'm gonna take another job and what should I do?
Should I tell him?
Should I not?
And we kind of went around and I was like,
look,
just tell them the truth.
Just say,
look,
hey,
this is what's going on.
I'm going to be,
I've got a better opportunity.
I'm going to take it.
Cause,
and in the long run,
you're in the long run.
It's going to be,
you're going to be better off if you're honest with people.
And so I obviously to think about this quality,
it's something I've,
I've thought about but not as clearly as this as,
as Dick winner saying.
That's the defining quality.
That's obviously important.
Something that I will talk about more now,
definitely believed it,
but we'll talk about it more
now.
If you've seen the movie band of brothers or the series band of brothers,
they,
they do a good job of showing the beginning when they form up and there's a guy,
there's a guy in leadership position called captains.
So bell and he's not a good leader and they do a good job of portraying why he
wasn't a good leader in the series.
But here's what Dick winters had to say about it.
Back to the book captain.
So bell commanded through fear and intimidation.
That is not how a leader should conduct himself.
Sabelle was not just unfair,
he was mean spirited.
His attitude created a special bond with an easy company that allowed the men to
identify with their platoons more so within with the company,
which is more normal in most units.
Military units,
second lieutenants by their nature are a clannish group.
So you've got a company commander and then he's got three,
usually three platoons underneath them,
and each one of those is run by a second lieutenant.
So the second lieutenants are the platoon commanders.
Second lieutenants,
by their nature are clannish group.
Some are more serious than others,
but for the most part they wander around a military post.
As General Eisenhower once said in a rather aimless search for excitement,
easy companies,
platoon leaders,
of which I was one,
did our best to take care of our soldiers to soften.
So bells,
dictatorial behavior,
I lost all respect for our commander the day he announced to the officers in
easy,
we will lead through fear,
not by example that that's just the opposite of any leadership principle that I
could ever conceive is to lead through fear instead.
Of example,
when you get,
well,
I don't know about your dad,
but if your dad says,
or if you say to your kids,
do what I say,
not what I do you know that you've heard that for sure.
For sure.
That's it.
And when,
if you want to put their fear onto that,
it's do what I say,
not what I do or else or else.
Yeah,
I'm going to get out the belt or the kids down south they say,
yeah,
I'm going to get out the switch.
Get out the switch.
Not all the time,
but you know he said that he said switch.
Where was he from?
That's from Brooklyn,
New York.
Then ain't got them switches in Brooklyn,
I'm here to tell you why they do our uncle,
why they found something wrong.
He made me go get my switch.
He said,
go get a switch.
I don't know what that means by the way.
At this point.
Oh,
because you're a little kid.
Yeah.
Go get an im from quiet.
They don't say switch.
You know?
Apparently other people say switch.
I didn't know which made them kind of more mad.
So then he had to brief you on what a switch was.
Yeah,
he didn't,
this is the thing I'm going to be,
it's kind of like digging your own grave in a way,
you know?
Very similar.
Yeah.
Back to the book,
it made such an impression on me that I recorded his words in my diary.
Under ordinary circumstances,
a junior company officer attempts to reflect his company commanders leadership
style,
but easy companies,
lieutenants found that they simply could not emulate the image of so bell and
still live with themselves.
Sabelle had no friends within the company and few within the regimen.
At the end of each day,
he went one way and we lieutenants when another hoping not to run into him at
the officer's club.
He lacked confidence in his own ability as an infantry commander.
He was,
he was completely honest,
but he couldn't read a map to save his neck.
His knowledge of tactics and fire maneuver was extremely poor.
So horrible situation.
And you know,
this is,
this is one of those things where he's talking about how everyone,
no one wants to hang around with them,
right?
And,
and I've heard leaders say,
Oh,
good beaders not going to be liked or not going to be loved by everyone.
And that there's some truth to that,
right?
Of course not.
Not everyone's going to love you,
but there's also a difference when no one likes you.
You're not doing a good job.
You're not doing a good job at all.
And you know,
I hung out with all my guys all the time through the chain of command,
everyone to hang out.
Let's go,
let's go,
let's,
let's hang out.
It wasn't good running away from me at the end of the war to escape.
That's,
that's not a good sign.
Yeah.
Lake one guys say I'm not here to make friends.
Yeah,
that's another classic right here to make friends.
No,
but I actually,
you know,
there's,
I heard,
I've heard officers say that in the military you see officers I've heard say
look your,
and now they'll say like,
hey,
it's not a popularity contest,
which is not,
clearly you're going to make decisions that can be hard for people to swallow,
but to have people running away from you because they don't like you as a human
being,
that's not a good position to be in your,
you're not doing a good job as a leader.
You need to reassess what you're,
what you're,
what you're doing and how you're doing it.
And this is kind of reflective of what Dick winters attitude was.
Back to the book.
Easy Company didn't belong to me.
It belonged to the soldiers.
I was privileged to be a small part of its history.
Officers and commanders in particular are merely caretakers that the
paratroopers respected me is more than enough reward.
So there's this totally,
totally different attitude.
Right.
And there is something weird that happens with the military.
You'll hear a guy a,
it's a,
it's a contradictory stay.
There's a dichotomy.
You'll hear a guy say my soldiers,
right?
Or my marines.
And there's two ways that that can be taken.
One of them is very positive.
My soldiers,
I am going to take care of my soldiers.
Hey,
don't come down here and talk to my soldiers like that,
right?
Or Hey,
you know,
I need to make sure my soldiers have the gear that they need.
I need to make sure my marines have,
and that's what they mean.
That in the best possible way,
there is another side to that which is completely negative,
which is these are my marines,
meaning you own them.
Meaning I'll do what I want with them,
right?
And so I've seen guys on both sides of that edge and you can hear a go,
you can hear a good leader say my marines,
you can hear a good leader say my soldiers are going to a good leader,
say my seals.
And think of it in a positive way and you can have a crappy leader.
Say,
my soldiers,
my marines,
my seals,
and you just think,
dude,
no stop.
And so for,
and especially when you get dick winters who was universally respected in his,
in the military and definitely in his battalion,
in his,
in his company.
And he's a guy that's saying,
look,
it was theirs that just tells you that's where your leadership perspective
should come from.
Yeah.
I always felt that better way instead of thing.
My,
one of the few things as far as feelings go cause I,
I,
I experienced that a lot when people would be like my,
this and that,
you know,
and if I see what you're doing and it's like you're just the boss and the owner
of all of this kind of thing,
you know,
kind of thing.
But with it felt like and feels like with people like my soldiers,
you know there is a lot of room for like cause cause men,
these are my brother.
Exactly.
You know my guys.
But let's say they're talking about like something else,
like a big one.
Um,
like the bartenders I used to work with,
every once in a while you'd have one say,
well,
Hey,
I got this and you know,
my bar.
And when they talk to the customers,
you know,
they'd be like,
Hey,
what kind of,
I don't know if God could he have?
He goes,
well,
my best vodka is,
you know,
this.
And that had been,
they'd say my,
you know,
kind of like I'm the master of this whole domain here.
Everything here is mine and that I can bestow upon you kind of feeling.
Yeah.
That always kind of will.
They do do it.
It definitely in the military with inanimate objects,
not just soldiers and marines and sailors,
they do it with inanimate objects.
And you learn that in boot camp,
you know,
they say,
why are you on my parade deck?
Right?
Yes.
It gives you this feeling of like,
Dang,
this guy's really into this parade deck.
Meaning you know,
where you do marching,
you know,
they say,
get off my parade deck.
Yeah.
And it instills that kind of personal pride about something.
So again,
even that one can go both ways.
I guess it really,
you really have to understand what your intent is behind what you're saying and
you have to be careful.
I,
I always,
I feel subconscious about that and I'll give you an example.
My Gym.
Yeah.
Right.
My Gym,
we're not going to talk about victory MMA,
which,
you know,
we have partners and it's not solely my gym know,
but it's my gym where I change train.
Right.
But sometimes someone will say something and I'll feel like,
oh,
where do you train?
You know,
and,
and I could say,
I trained at my gym.
You know what I mean?
I feel like a real turd when I do that.
I got all victory.
Emma van fitness,
you know.
Oh,
D Mr. Jeff Glover.
Yeah.
That's where I trained and oh wait,
do you own that place?
Yeah,
yeah.
I'm one of the owners,
you know,
blah,
blah blah.
But yeah,
don't like that.
My,
Oh,
you get to sit in there for what a careful,
be careful with that too.
I always thought if you said our,
you know,
especially even in a bartender situation what we have,
it's kind of like us as a,
as an establishment,
right.
You know,
kind of thing.
I'm part of that.
When you say are your part of it,
you know,
so it kind of still puts that forward.
Like I'm kind of giving this to you or offering whatever.
I'm taking some ownership,
but it's like I'm not the boss of this thing.
It kind of feels that way.
That's what I always thought.
Even if you like in your situation,
if you were like,
you know,
someone say,
hey doc already trained,
we say,
well at our gym,
you know,
and it's kind of ambiguous as well,
which kindness seems more humble,
you know,
where it's like,
oh yeah,
you could be just a member,
but at least you're part of that community,
you know,
kind of thing.
So yeah,
they use are careful.
That's all I'm saying.
You gotta be careful,
be careful with my marines,
my soldiers.
And again,
sometimes that's the most positive thing he could possibly say,
these are my seals.
Hey,
don't come down here and figuring to put my seals out in the field in a bad
situation.
It's not happening.
You know what I mean?
Your protective,
they're your brothers,
you know you have ownership of them,
but it's,
it's in a positive way as opposed to look all deploy my seals wherever I see
fit.
Like oh put a,
put a red flag on that dude's face.
Right
back to the book.
I think of easy company every day we sustained 150% casualties between the night
that we jumped into Normandy at v e day,
150% capital.
So for those of you that are wondering how you do that,
how you do that is you have people getting wounded multiple times and coming
back to the front and when your replacement show up they get wounded too.
So you,
you know,
you've got whatever,
150 people in your,
in your company and over the course of time people get wounded and leave and new
people come in to take their place and they get wounded as well.
And that's how you get up.
Over a hundred percent of your people being wounded.
The result of sharing all the stress throughout training and combat has created
a bond between the metal VZ company that will last forever.
In a sense,
I don't think I ever left company E.
I may never against you the type of men in this outfit,
but to me,
easy company will always be my company in the sense that I will always remain a
part of it.
To this day they remain my second family.
I still look at these men with great respect,
respect.
I can't describe in words,
so there he makes it.
Same thing like he feels uncomfortable saying mine.
He has to put a quantifier on it and explained,
Hey,
not in that sense,
but I'll always be a part of it.
That's why it's mine.
More about leadership.
Back to the book,
leadership is difficult to define.
They talk about leadership at West Point every day.
Leadership starts with honesty,
dedication,
and having a man who is dependable and fair.
If you never deviate from the standards that you established,
men have faith in you and you'll be out front to set the example.
Sergeant Talbert once told me,
sir,
I'd follow you into hell.
I take a great deal of pride in his remark.
So again,
we're getting this leadership starts with honesty,
dedication,
dependable and fair.
So important,
so important,
being fair.
And you know,
you see that a lot when it comes at doling out punishment.
When people make mistakes,
are you fair enough?
You know,
does that person really deserve to lose their pay for 90 days or go on bread and
water or whatever kind of punishment you're going to bestow on someone.
Is that fair?
And people know if things are fair or not.
Yeah,
people know what's reasonable.
Hey,
do you think that,
you know,
when people say,
I'm going to make an example out of somebody before,
sometimes it'd be,
it's for different reasons.
Maybe be like,
oh,
I've been letting people slack,
so I gotta I got to make an example out of somebody to kind of reestablish the
kind of thing,
or maybe you know,
as a boss or whatever,
you really don't like the specific violation.
Like you've just re,
it's just one of your things,
you know,
so you can make an example for that reason.
Do you think that that's fair?
It can be,
but it's also a touchy subject.
You tell me.
I personally think,
let's say I'd been given some slack and people been showing up a little bit
late,
showing up a little bit late and I'm Kinda like,
hey man,
you know,
we need to be a little more in time.
And then finally on a Thursday,
guy shows up late for the meeting and I say,
hey,
you're suspended.
You're grounded.
You're,
you know,
you're gonna have to work this weekend.
I punish them hard,
super hard.
That doesn't make sense.
Right,
right.
And it doesn't make sense.
And people say,
Oh,
you know,
I'm not good.
It's not being consistent because people have been being met.
However,
if I was to say,
hey guys,
check it out,
Bill just walking in right now and I've been letting it slide and I'll tell you
what,
this is where it's getting us.
We'd been later and later we start slacking here.
We're going to start slacking in other places.
We can't afford to slack right now.
Our is to important from now on if we're late,
if you're late showing up to this meeting or you're late to an evolution that
we're about to do,
I'm going to drop the hammer so don't be late.
Is that fair?
Yeah.
Fair warning explanation as to why that's fair in my opinion.
Just going off the handle and smashing someone because you want to make an
example of them.
That doesn't make sense to me.
Yeah.
I don't like it.
I don't do it.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
That'd be useful.
Yes.
If someone,
if there's a clearly delineated expectation that's been set and it gets violated
for whatever reason and you are going to crush and destroy.
To set an example and actually we get to a point where he talks about that in
here or there is an example set and that has to send a message to everyone.
Yeah that can do that.
I've done that with my family,
you know,
hey here's the line.
If you cross it you will remember for a very long time that you made a bad
decision.
Yeah.
And my other kids when I've done that too,
some of them,
you know,
one of my kids that has made a bad decision,
they all remember all of them.
They don't want to make that mistake.
Yeah.
It seems like you cross the line.
No,
not at all.
Like how you said if you give them kind of ample warning where you kind of give
them the tools to make their own decision kind of thing.
Even if you are changing a policy or whatever,
you know a harsher punishment punishment's all this stuff as long as yeah.
You warn them like how you were saying that seems like fair and the huge one,
which I always kind of thought was if it applies to everyone,
you know like if if this violation,
this punishment for this violation applies to everyone.
Sure.
It just happens to be this guy cause he just happened.
He's be the one,
he happens to be the one that committed the violation or whatever.
But this rule,
this policy applies to everybody.
Yeah.
And also when you,
when you explain these things,
you don't blame them.
If you notice,
even when I just said,
you know,
hey guys,
I bring in slack hair.
You don't say,
look,
you guys miss I can do.
I said look,
I didn't make it clear why this is important.
Yeah.
And therefore you guys have been,
you know,
I've been letting you slack.
You guys have been showing up late.
That's a problem.
We can't have that problem anymore.
So you just don't start pointing the fingers and everywhere.
Yeah.
And then hammering them.
Harsher punishments.
No,
not a good idea.
Speaking of leadership back to the book,
I believe that some men and women are born with the inherent qualities that make
them good leaders.
Writing to his son John,
who was a cadet at west point in 1943 general Eisenhower once said,
the one quality that can be developed by studious reflection and practice is the
leadership of men.
I agree with Ike.
Leaders are not born leaders are made and they are made by solid effort and hard
work.
So there's a little contradictory in there because he says,
look,
some people are born with qualities that make them a good leader,
but you can learn to be a good leader.
I totally agree with that.
I've always said that some people have the qualities that make them a good
leader naturally.
Are they a lot of,
some of them,
right?
Some of them are be really articulate.
Some of them will be very charismatic,
very dynamic,
loud,
have a lot of presence.
Those are all characteristics that will differentiate in different people and if
you have a lot of those,
you'll going to have a naturally easier time being a good leader.
Now,
occasionally you get people that have some of those qualities but they're idiots
and those are the worst cause they can get people to follow him even though they
don't know where they're going.
Those are bad situations,
but it's interesting,
hard work studying,
right?
Studying leadership.
You know,
today I already learned something need to increase my focus on honesty as a
leadership quality.
But yeah,
I'm always studying,
always learning and we all need to be,
that's how we're going to become a better leader.
And a lot of the studying that I did when I was growing up in the teams was
just,
I was watching in thinking about why these leaders were doing what they're doing
well,
one is making them do this good leader.
Why is,
wow,
why does that,
why do we respond to that?
Well,
bad leader,
why don't really respond well to what he's doing?
I wasn't sitting there consciously thinking about it.
Actually No.
In some cases I was actually consciously thinking about it.
You know,
consciously thinking,
wait,
why is no one want to follow this guy?
How is he acting that we all want to walk away from him?
Why is that happening?
And then when you get a good leader,
I'd say this,
why is this guy such a good leader?
So yeah,
I guess I did consciously do that and study not from books but from life to try
and learn and that's how you can become better.
Here's a little note to
and and you want to talk about holding the line.
If you aren't in good physical shape,
forget it.
You are not going to be a good leader.
Well,
certainly in a military environment.
That is true there.
Are there some civilian leaders that aren't in the best shape?
Yeah,
there are.
With those leaders be doing a better job if they were in better physical
condition.
Yes they would.
It's like that.
That thing that starting strength.
Coach Rippetoe says,
I post,
I'm never talked about it,
but I posted it.
You know,
he's talking about how physical strength is good and people that say that
physical strength aren't good.
He says,
you know,
I forget the exact quote,
but he's basically saying,
I,
I know physical strength is good,
and if you take someone that says the physical strength isn't good
and is an important,
and then you add 120 pounds to their squat and then ask them how they're doing
now,
they're going to be doing better.
They're going to be doing better.
The more you can dead lift,
the better you're going to feel.
You don't feel worse when you can deadlift more.
You don't feel worse than when you could squat more.
You feel better.
Yeah.
Well,
why is that?
There's a million reasons why confidence overcoming the challenge.
You're actually physically stronger.
Your mental clarity goes up,
so yeah,
of course,
be in good shape,
be in good shape.
If you're worried about your health,
you're not going to be able to focus on being a good leader and in the military
or in any job where that demands physical exertion,
you have to be in good shape.
Otherwise people are looking at you and you're falling apart.
You can't be falling apart on a patrol.
You can't be falling apart during,
uh,
during our combat swimming operation where you,
you know,
you need to swim,
you need to swim far,
you're going to swim for four straight hours on a combat swimmer operation.
If you're weak and you can't do that,
you think your men are going to respect you.
They're not.
I'll go ahead and answer that question for you.
Does that kind of like the hockey coach who doesn't even know how to Ice Skate?
You know,
there are coaches that have never participated in a sport that they coach and
they're good there.
I mean,
you can look at Greg Jackson who's a great mixed martial arts coach.
He's never been in mixed martial arts fighter.
Yeah.
But he knows how to fight though,
you know?
Yeah.
It certainly does.
Yes.
But he hasn't actually fought.
So how can he be a good coach?
What about Duke Roufus?
He's never fought MMA.
Has He?
Oh,
MMA he's got moved.
Yeah.
We know he's a champion.
Kickboxer but how can it be such a great coach at MMA?
Yeah.
Cause you can connect the dots and stuff like that.
And of course there's,
you know,
there's exceptions,
but generally speaking,
and plus you're talking about a little bit more of a broad thing like a leader.
Like who,
who are we going to follow plus some,
cause we're talking about coaches,
you coaches are,
are not participating anymore.
That's why they're coaching.
Yeah.
I guess those are really stupid examples
because,
because you know,
custom motto with Mike Tyson,
obviously he wasn't getting in the ring with Mike Tyson,
right?
Yeah.
But he's a great coach,
a fantastic coach,
one of the most,
you know,
one of the most respected coaches of all time.
Yeah.
And the results are a little bit more like,
um,
recognizable,
like they're less ambiguous,
like a leader's results quote.
And we're looking at,
we're looking at leaders in the field,
like leaders in the job that are leading a group to accomplish a mission.
Right.
That's different than a coach.
A coach is outside the group.
Yeah.
Huh.
So we're talking about someone that's in the group.
Yeah.
You gotta be,
you gotta be able to maintain,
you gotta be able to stay with your team physically.
And you know,
it's not like you need to be the best.
I was never the fastest guy was never the strongest guy,
but I wasn't going to be fallen behind on a patrol because I wasn't in good
shape.
That wasn't going to happen and the only way,
the way that doesn't happen is you need to stay in shape.
How do you stay in shape?
Got To have discipline.
Yeah.
These questions answer themselves at some point.
Maybe some point.
This podcast,
we'll just come on here and sit here in silence.
Yeah.
Speaking of now,
this is,
this is good that you,
you were talking about this here is a heavy punishment handed out.
Talking about Colonel Bob Sync,
who was the leader of the,
uh,
five oh six parachute infantry regiment.
We go back to the book.
Colonel Bob Sync certainly was one of the best.
He set high standards and never compromised on those standards.
After the paratroopers of the 506 paratrooper,
paratrooper,
parachute,
infantry regiment earned their jump wings sync granted a 10 day furlough,
but caution the men to conduct themselves appropriately.
Several paratroopers reported late for duty after their furloughs expired.
Saint called another regimental formation and publicly humiliated one
paratrooper from each of his nine companies.
They called out the name of the last soldier to report to duty and that
paratrooper was marched in front of the formation under escort and officer
stripped him of his unit patch,
forced him to unblock [inaudible] boots
and then escorted him from the field.
What sink was saying was paratroopers may be elite,
but they had to follow the army's rules and regulations.
I liked that for some reason,
sync liked me,
respected me.
He was always the man instrumental in getting me my next job.
So there's a heavy punishment.
Now
that's,
that's a clear message being sent,
right?
Clear message being sent.
And I,
I,
I bet colonel sink at that time,
Wade mean he's got three,
nine companies.
So he's got hundreds and hundreds of guys,
hundreds and hundreds of guys,
and he's going to make an example out of nine of them and he's going to be a
real clear example and that's going to leave an impression on a thousand guys
are,
you know,
close to a thousand guys that might be worth it and he probably judged that it
was worth,
yeah.
So interesting perspective.
Yeah.
I think if the question is,
is that fair?
I would say I would say to the guys that got booted from the regiment,
I'd say their thoughts were that it was unfair.
I would say for the guys that remained in the regiment that realized that they
had to maintain the standard that realize there was going to be no slack and
that worked hard to make sure they maintain that and therefore we're more
prepared for combat.
Let's say it was real fair,
right,
so bigger picture kind of thing.
They were kind of the martyr.
Yeah.
That gets a real big picture thing and who knows what kind of behind the scenes,
and we would have to get some details if we were really going to cast judgment
on that.
Like uh,
you know,
maybe some of those guys were kind of slackers anyways and the company commander
was like,
hey dude,
yeah,
we don't want this guy.
You know,
let's get rid of this guy or whatever.
You know.
And he only took certain members of the people that miss their furlough.
He,
so he didn't even say that's not fair.
He only took certain members or certain people that that missed their furlough.
Didn't take all of them.
Yeah,
just the last one to report.
We don't,
we don't take that around here.
It's an interesting dynamic.
It's an interesting dynamic,
but it's definitely showing.
I don't know that I necessarily would have done that.
I can I,
my assumption,
my,
my assessment I probably wouldn't have.
Yeah.
Not,
not one guy from each company.
Maybe like the two guys that grossly violated it.
I don't think I would need to do nine.
You know?
Guess what?
Conal sink Dan.
Don't mess with Colonel Sink and that's a good thing.
Little little kind of image for you to have like don't mess with Colonel Sink.
Don't mess around in the battalion in the regimen we don't play.
Another leader that he talks about here is Mcauliffe.
Back to the book,
what we liked about Mcauliffe was that he allowed us to do our jobs.
You didn't have a lot of interference from Mcauliffe,
but with Taylor and command,
this is another person.
He told you what you needed to do here.
He had to run everything.
You can't do a good job if you don't have the chance to use your imagination and
creativity.
In my mind,
Taylor was more interested in impressing his superiors.
Then watching out for his men.
Taylor was such a contrast with British General Montgomery,
so he talks a little bit.
Oh,
okay.
So first of all,
clearly decentralized command.
Don't give people the clear specifics on how to do every little thing.
Let them get creative.
Let them come up with a solution.
Perfect.
Boom.
We hear that over and over again.
Why do we hear it over and over again?
Because it's right because it's right.
That's why we hear it over and over again.
Now he talks about the famous British General Montgomery Monty,
who always gets portrayed a little bit stiff and a little bit British.
Right,
and he says in here that the writers don't,
didn't know him,
didn't see him on the battlefield,
didn't see what he was like,
and here's what he says.
Here's what Dick Winter said about Montgomery.
Back to the book of Montgomery was the real deal.
I saw him on a number of occasions and he always impressed me as a commander who
lived the lifestyle that was beyond reproach for his staff to follow.
He set the example.
He addressed every division that was scheduled to participate in the invasion.
He called us together and had every soldier take off his helmet so he could see
the troops better.
Yeah,
props to Monte,
right?
Going around and and talking to every,
every single division
and then said,
hey boys,
take off your helmets.
I want to see your faces before you roll.
It's legit props.
There's,
you know,
this book,
a lot of this book is about self discipline.
Even this part right here,
back to the book.
Self-Disciplined keeps you doing your job.
Without it,
you lose your pride and forget the importance of self respect and the eyes of
your fellow men.
Pride keeps you going on.
This is what I feared.
I would lose the loss of the will to measure up to my men.
So once you say,
you know what,
I don't care what my guys think anymore.
You've asked it right?
If I say,
look,
I don't care what the guys think of me,
think of what a driving force it is to have your team looking at you and saying,
I'm going to make sure these guys respect me and I'm proud of what I'm doing
compared to I don't care what anyone thinks to me anymore.
And you can see whether you can see what,
when this happens to people,
not just in the military or a business organization,
but in life,
in the life.
At a certain point,
you see a bomb in the street.
At a certain point that bum said,
you know what?
I don't care what anyone thinks of me anymore.
I don't care what my family thinks me,
I don't care what the society thinks of me.
Of course I'm not talking about every single bum.
But a lot of them,
yeah.
They,
I don't care generally to the thing.
And as soon as you see that,
you can imagine that that's just like a life thing,
right?
Yeah.
If you go through life and you said,
don't care what anyone else thinks,
which is a contradiction for me,
right?
Because I'll say all the time,
like I don't care what people think.
Yeah.
But that's too,
just to a degree like you and it's obvious and just put a little bit of thought
into.
You don't care about what people think.
Well as it appears.
You don't care what people think on a superficial level,
you know,
on a profound level.
You do you,
that's why you're,
you know,
that's what part of your morality is like,
fairness,
doing the right thing,
all this discipline stuff.
It's for you.
But in regards to social cues and all these things,
like that's beneficial to your success to function in a society.
And I've said this before,
like about the seal teams and me being in the seal teams and I had this
completely had this attitude.
I don't care.
Like for instance,
I don't care what happens,
like I don't care if I get fired,
I'm going to do the right thing.
I don't care.
I don't care what they think of me.
And at the same thing,
at the same time,
there's nothing that was more important than to me than my reputation in the
seal teams.
I don't want,
you know,
if,
if something was going to give you a bad reputation,
like what we just talked about,
if you fall out of a patrol as a leader or as anyone,
like if you fall out of patrol,
you're going to you.
No one's ever gonna Forget it.
In the seal teams,
if you're too weak to do something,
you're going to be remembered by that forever and that,
I didn't want that ever to be like,
oh,
Jocko did this.
Jocko couldn't finish patrol.
Jocko was a bad leader.
Jocko,
I didn't want that to be the reality.
And so therefore you work hard,
you stay in shape,
you do your best all the time.
Yeah.
And that drives you.
But at the same time I wasn't saying,
Oh,
I,
I'm concerned what my boss thinks of me,
so I'm going to act a certain way.
No,
I was trying to do the right thing for the teams right away.
See what I'm saying though?
Like these are the,
these are all tubes.
Those are all fundamental things.
Yeah.
It's weird.
It's a weird balance though to say,
look,
I don't care if I get promoted,
but I care more than anything about my job.
You know what I mean?
And that definitely was my attitude.
That definitely was my attitude my whole time.
I was in the military.
Look,
I'm,
I'm going to do the best job I can.
I'm not doing it to get promoted.
I'm not doing it for that reason,
but I am part of it.
Absolutely.
Doing it to have the respect of my peers and my bros and the teams.
Right.
You wouldn't be in a reputation.
You hear that all the time.
Your reputation is everything in the seal teams because it's a small group of
people,
you know you have an accidental discharge with your weapon.
Everybody knows about it and they're gonna know about it forever.
A few,
if you remain on the teams for whatever reason,
after you have an accidental discharge,
everyone's going to know it from there on out and it's not fun.
That's where we got Matt,
Jim Jacked up nicknames in the seal teams because you're going to get nicknamed
African your lowest point in your life.
The biggest mistake is what you're going to get nicknamed or your biggest.
Yeah,
like there was a guy and his nickname was Bush and he's a great dude.
His nickname was Bush,
had nothing to do his last name,
but anyways,
long story short,
when he was a new guy,
and I knew this is 15 years later,
I found this out,
he said he'd been in the seal teams for 15 years.
I'd known him as Bush the whole time and he was parachuting.
Brand new guy,
showed up to the team.
They're like,
hey,
you're going jumping today.
Okay.
It gets into aircraft jumps and he,
he lands through no fault.
You can't even steer these brown parachutes.
You can't barely stay him.
He lands in a Bush with like forums and you're right.
And I guess it looks pretty funny.
And from there on,
is it,
what's his name?
Bush.
Yeah.
So you're going to get a name like that.
But that's a,
that's a really easy example because everybody knows,
hey,
that's just funny.
It was more of a funny thing.
If something funny happens to you,
you might get that nickname too.
Like if you get pepper sprayed by the cops,
you might have the nickname pepper.
I like the direct it is.
Yeah.
There's no sense in playing around.
What else are you going call someone that gets pepper sprayed by the cops were
there new guy.
You're gonna call them pepper.
You call him when I or something I,
cause I just get all water.
You have to not,
you're not gonna be in charge of nature.
Remember your guide that you thought to name was his name was Al Big Al 50 cal.
Not even his name or his name.
Big outfit.
The Cow.
Yeah.
Morphed is awesome,
so that's why you have this weird dichotomy that's pulling at you is just to,
you're looking at your,
your friends,
your peers in this,
in a leadership position.
It's your men.
You're looking at your men saying,
Hey,
I don't want to let these guys down.
I don't want them to view me as weak weeks.
Bad word,
but actually I guess it's the word I'm looking for.
Not that I,
not that I want to maintain the image of strength because part of maintaining
the image of strength is by showing weakness and being like,
I say this all the time,
hey,
I don't know how to do this.
Hey,
can you give me a suggestion?
I'm not talking about that type of thing.
I'm talking about
physical weakness,
physical and mental toughness or physical and mental weakness.
Right?
That's a lot different than,
hey,
I don't understand how to do something or,
or it's a lot different than humility.
You can,
you can want to show,
you can want to maintain strength but still have humility for sure.
No,
I know all kinds of,
I mean,
I know tons of guys that are completely humble,
but they're the toughest bastard you'd ever want to know mentally and
physically,
so I'm not talking about I need to be strong,
stronger than everyone.
No,
I'm not talking about that at all.
I'm talking about your physical and mental toughness you have to have,
and if you don't have him as a leader,
could be problematic.
Yeah,
watch out for it.
Back to the book,
the big thing I derived from combat was the necessity of maintaining discipline,
discipline,
and our troops was discipline in our troops and getting the job done in combat.
So clearly discipline's a big part of what we're talking about here.
Gee,
I wonder why now this is
talking to another little aspect that you know,
I don't talk about this a lot.
I think it's inherent in a lot of things that I say,
but it's not something that,
I don't use this word a lot,
and again,
I think I need to use it more.
Back to the book.
Character rose revolves around doing the right thing all the time.
Character implies daily choices of right over wrong.
The cadet prayer at westpoint says,
cadet strive to choose the harder right instead of the easier,
wrong and never to be content with a half truth when the whole can be one that
gets to the heart of character.
I would add that it is easier to do the right thing when everyone is looking.
It is more difficult to do what you should do when you are alone.
I like to think of character as every other virtue at the breaking point.
So character,
doing the right thing,
doing the right thing at all times,
doing the right thing when you're alone.
Back to the book.
A war doesn't alter character wore,
merely brings out the best that an individual has to offer.
Unfortunately,
it also brings forth the worst in some men.
If anything,
war exposes the best and worst of those who are called to fight.
I know of no man who lacked character and peace and then discovered character in
combat.
So I've said this same type of thing before,
especially,
I mean war.
You know,
what we'd see on deployment is as pressure starts to build on people,
you start seeing people go in two directions,
then that's what we'd see their character would start to reveal itself.
They either get very,
they'd rise to the occasion or they would not,
and they'd go in the other direction and become worse.
Their character would become worse or their character would become better.
That's what I've seen.
And the same thing,
you know,
when we talk about people that have
maybe have a hard time dealing with war,
a lot of times there's some preexisting issues that the war in flames,
right?
And then if you take someone that has,
that doesn't have preexisting issues or maybe has a positive spin on things and
that becomes more positive.
So it's very,
and then there's a bunch of people in the middle,
but some of the guys that I knew that really had a hard time,
they had issues going in,
you know,
they had problems,
some issues going in to the situation going into war.
And those problems get exacerbated by the pressure and the stress of combat.
So we need to watch out for that one.
I think.
I think war is more of an amplifier that a creator,
I think it amplifies good character.
I think it amplifies bad character.
I think it amplifies issues and in either direction.
So it's,
it's a,
it's a powerful element to add into people's lives.
This,
this big intense piece.
Now,
one of the things that this let this book captures is these letters.
He kind of had a pen pal,
a female pen pal when he was at war.
Her name is Deanna almonds.
And one of the things that he,
he,
so he,
so they capture these letters and some of the letters,
parts,
some of the letters are published in here.
Here's one of them.
Back to the book first and most important,
I've got my own conscience to answer to next,
my parents.
And then I am an officer in the U s army.
I am damn proud of it.
And with the rank and position I hold,
I wouldn't think of doing anything to bring discredit to my outfit,
my paratrooper boots,
wings,
the airborne patch or the U s army.
Good morale within an outfit is usually reflected by good conduct away from it.
That sounds like an idealistic high school kid.
I know,
but that's it.
That's how I feel.
So he took that stuff very,
very seriously.
And I remember,
I remember the dirt prewar I was in my third platoon and the the new guys who
are all my bros now,
I mean these are just mugs,
but they were new guys and we were the senior older guys,
right.
Because we'd been in the teams for like a couple of years and something happened
and we gave like a,
like a like,
hey guys,
don't,
don't ever make the platoon look bad.
Like no matter what,
you don't make the platoon look bad.
That's not allowed.
But we'll tune is comes first above everything.
And this one I just remember saying,
but then one guy made,
the platoon looked bad and he had to pay for it.
But that's the attitude.
The attitude was like,
look,
you don't make the platoon to look bad.
You don't make the teams look bad.
We didn't really,
we weren't too concerned with the navy back then.
We didn't really even feel like when I was that young and the seal teams that we
weren't even thinking about the big navy.
We barely even recognized it.
We were in the teams.
It's more,
it's as as as the teams became bigger and more prevalent,
we connected more with the big navy,
but when I was a new guy in the suit,
when I was in the seal teams as a young guy in the 90s we were pretty much on
her own,
so I wasn't,
I basically,
I wasn't like sitting there and thinking handy.
You protect the reputation of the navy.
I didn't care.
I would now as I got older I did,
but back in the day it was like,
Hey,
the platoon and I was at team one at the time and team one you'll make team one
look bad.
What are you doing?
Don't make this book tune.
Look bad.
You just did that.
Yeah.
Now you have to pay for that.
Punishment
will be delivered at this time and it was,
that's a,
that's a unfortunate situation and know these things just happen from time to
time.
So are we not going into what the punishment was that day?
The punishment,
the punishment was,
I'll tell you what the punishment was,
Jocko punishment,
the punishment was I am going to strike you two times in the face with an open
hand.
That's punishment or we're going to fight which one do you want.
That was the punishment he in and this guy was like,
I'll take the two.
And I was like Roger that and there was a little bit more tension than that,
you know,
cause he was kind of like boat up a little bit.
Yeah.
And I was like,
Oh,
if you want to get it on we'll get it on.
And then,
and you know,
it's funny because these guys,
this group of guys who was,
they were,
they were all guys just trying to get after it and be good team guys.
But we were just crazy,
you know,
at this point.
And the teams was literally everything in my life.
So when I was like mad about disrespecting or making the platoon look bad,
it need like hurt me.
I was that crazy that I just didn't want the platoon to look bad.
Yeah.
You know,
when you did something that made the platoon the pad,
yeah.
It bothered me.
It really,
truly bothered me.
You made something that made team on look,
I mean,
I'd been there,
you know,
since I was a kid and it was everything to me.
And so when you didn't,
when you made us look bad,
I wasn't happy and not just,
I wasn't happy because I was a jerk or I wasn't because I was being a jerk at
the time.
But talking to these guys,
you know,
years later we talked to these guys.
They're like,
yeah,
that guy in particular,
he's like,
I hated going to work.
I hated you guys.
And I was like,
yeah,
I'm sorry.
You know?
And,
and then there'll be like,
but I'm glad it was like that because everybody has that feeling.
It was the old school.
It was like with the old breed,
you know,
hey,
this is the way it is.
This,
we hold the line.
We don't make the platoon look bad.
We make the two look good.
We work hard.
That's what we do.
It was like a little gang.
Yeah.
That's all it was.
That's crazy.
Those two choices,
cause they're like,
they're just different because some people would rather go do the fight because
you know,
at least the kind of go down,
swinging and kind of attitude.
But the potential for damage is way more than enough.
Like you know what I'm saying?
But,
and then I agree with you and you could see where you could make a case for both
of those selections.
But there's also something called,
it's like,
I'll take two hits to the face,
open hand.
Cool.
I'm a man.
I screwed up that.
I think that's the,
the reason I respected it was because it wasn't.
It was like,
yeah,
I did screw up.
Right.
So I'll just,
and I'll take it.
I deserve punishment.
Give it to me.
Yeah.
And that was that.
Well then we move on.
No factor.
Yeah.
Technically the two to the face or is way easier because it's way quicker.
You,
you know,
you know what to expect.
I mean,
unless you're scared of like,
oh,
hitting your head.
And dying or something,
you know,
some off they were opening though.
They were open hand.
Yeah.
See,
so clear.
Not going to knock anybody out with a open hand.
Yeah.
Well usually you're not,
you know,
maybe I could,
I'm just kidding.
But um,
yeah,
so a lot of that is that how you say you were kind of building some tension with
it.
It's like that's a big part of the punishment as well.
That's psychological torture.
And this also reveals my own personal immaturity,
right?
These are like,
seriously,
this is what I'm thinking about it.
This is just an immature,
you know,
I was probably 22 years old,
maybe 23 years old,
but you know,
young and immature and not getting the best guidance,
not understanding things,
not understanding that I wasn't helping build a cohesive unit,
not understanding that this guy's probably thinking,
oh,
I don't want to help him.
You know what I mean?
It wasn't smart.
I'm not,
I'm not trying to say that this stuff was smart.
I'm telling you,
the reality of the way it was and the way it was in my head was,
hey,
this is my life,
this seal platoon.
I know it's,
it's,
it sounds crazy.
This seal platoon that we're in is my whole life and I actually don't care about
anything else.
Mind you,
this is in the 90s there's no war going on.
I'm just a young,
crazy kid.
And the only thing I know,
and the only thing I care about is the seal teams and that,
you know,
you make the to look bad.
This platoon is my life and you just made us look bad.
And I can't stand that.
And I don't want it to be that way.
So young,
immature me,
what do I do?
Hey this,
there's gotta be a punishment,
you know?
And that's kind of the attitude we had.
And
there are some benefits to it,
but you know,
it's our wave.
I would love to go back and be a better mentor and be like,
Hey man,
this is the mistake you made.
You know,
we need to make,
you know,
I would love to do that.
But you can't,
you're a dumb,
I was a young,
dumb kid that was raised that way by the way as well.
That's how we were raised and there are some benefits to it.
And like I said,
even those guys that did platoons with me when I was quote unquote an old guy,
even though we were nothing,
we'd never been to combat,
we were meaningless,
but we had a couple more years in the seal teams.
So therefore you're an old guy and the new guys or anyone with,
with no deployments,
which is actually pathetic in its own right because the term in the seal teams
being,
Oh,
you're a new guy that was from guys that were in Vietnam that you hadn't been in
combat.
Yes.
Or you're a newborn.
You're cherry boy.
So guess what?
I was a cherry boy for 13 years because I never shot my weapon at the end.
I mean,
I hadn't been in combat until I went to my first deployment to Iraq.
So there's actually,
from that perspective,
it's embarrassing because here I was big.
I'm an old guy.
It was an old guy.
I never been in combat before.
What am I talking about?
Yeah,
but you,
you,
you take what you had at the time,
which was this organization,
the seal teams.
My platoon,
and again,
you can't,
I can't describe really how important the seal platoon was to me it was,
well,
let me put it this way.
It was my whole life and you go,
what I do when I woke up in the morning,
went in,
went into work,
worked out with my seal platoon mates.
What do we do then we worked all day.
What do we do for lunch?
We ate together.
What do we do at night?
We went and got dinner.
What do we do after that?
We went and had drinks.
We hung out all night.
What do we do after that?
We went to sleep,
woke up and did the same thing that day after day.
That was my family.
And you just have this,
this passion for your family and you,
it just meant it was the most important thing in the world to be for my whole
adult life.
But when you take that and you put that on a,
you know,
young kid.
Yeah.
And you know everyone's like,
oh yeah.
Jockos he reads a big reader.
I wasn't reading anything back then.
I was reading the fourtune tune handbook.
Right.
I wasn't reading,
I wasn't reading Shakespeare.
Sure.
Yeah.
I,
what was I doing in high school?
I wasn't paying attention during high school.
I was wanting to be a commando.
I was running through the woods pretending I had a machine gun.
So you take that kid and you put them in a situation where the thing that he
cares about the most has been scorn,
violated,
or score.
He's going to try and handle it to the best of his abilities.
Start slapping,
not proud of it,
but occasionally some people that slapped around.
Yeah.
That's how though,
you know,
you know when your basic young,
basic guy,
you can handle things in a young,
basic kind of way.
Yeah.
Whatever.
It's it's caveman.
Yes.
Caveman scenario.
There you go.
And,
and,
and the other thing is,
and you know,
those guys that were in those early platoons when I was like,
I said up quote unquote old Lear's later,
they're like,
yeah,
that was awesome.
So glad I got raised that way.
They're proud of it,
you know?
But at the same time,
you,
uh,
when I look back on it,
I know I was not a good leader right.
By any stretch.
Yeah.
That's kind of like when I look at my old videos at the time,
I'm like,
yeah,
they were dope.
You know,
but,
and you're like me,
you just know better ways now.
You know,
you're just,
you just better know hindsight 2021 and the other thing you've got to be careful
of is setting the bar.
Like let's say I was in a seal platoon right now and now I'm going to set the
bar so high that I lose track of lose vision of the fact that like,
Hey,
the guy that I'm trying to convince right now as a 23 year old thing and the
most important thing in his world is,
this is funny.
Like I was talking to someone the other day and was like,
I couldn't remember what singable tune,
what the phonetic letter of a certain seal platoon I was in at a certain time.
I was like,
I forget what platoon that was.
Yeah.
And to me at the time when we were in those seal platoons,
that letter of that phonetic alphabet,
we were an Alpha platoon.
That was it.
And now I look back and it's like,
oh yeah,
what platoon was that?
Because as I matured and as I saw the rest of the world,
I realized that even though a seal platoon is very important,
and it certainly,
it's the most important thing when you're in it,
when you're in a task unit or you're overseas and there's multiple people
running around and there's huge missions going,
ew,
ope,
your mind gets opened up.
Yeah.
And you see more and the,
the little thing that you used to be so engulfed in your head becomes becomes
less.
That's all there is to it.
Now I'm telling you guys in the seal platoons,
there's no better job.
Like it's the best thing in the world.
And I'm sure,
you know,
I had never served in the marine corps,
infantry platoon or in a,
you know,
army,
US Army infantry,
but I saw them,
I saw,
they were like,
and they have that same bond that,
that you get from being in those tough units.
So there's something very cool about that,
about being a grunt,
which is what you are in the seal teams.
You might think Alma special operations or whatever.
You're a grunt,
you're,
you carry a machine gun.
Yeah.
And you do hard things.
That's what being a grunt is.
You're doing hard things.
You're carrying a bunch of weight around
those days.
Love those days.
Yeah.
All right.
So I just wanted to be back in a sealed so bad.
Yeah.
And it's so fun.
So awesome.
So meaningful.
I would have fought you.
Yeah.
What happened?
You know,
what would have happened?
I don't know.
Bailey,
that was one of the good things about knowing a little tiny bit of Jujitsu,
which I actually knew a little bit.
Yeah,
that was enough.
Yeah.
You got guys with Co,
what's the offer to fight them?
And they kick your ass or you're like,
Dang,
that backfired.
And here's the thing,
they didn't know any better.
All they thought was they didn't,
I don't think I ever said like,
I know Jujitsu and you don't,
but it was just,
I was so confident like,
oh,
I actually know this and I know that I can choke this dude that they just said,
you know what?
This guy's probably gonna kick my ass.
And the weird thing is there's probably guys along the way that could've kicked
ass.
You know,
some kid that wrestled in high school,
we all double leg,
boom,
and now I'm slammed on the ground and getting punched in the head.
I don't,
I can't,
you know,
it's less than not learned.
Yeah.
Less than not learned.
I'm lucky that never happened.
You know?
So check.
All right,
here we're talking about,
so I just was talking about,
this is interesting.
So I was just talking about mental strength and physical strength.
Well,
here we go back to the book moral courage.
Courage is a far rarer commodity than physical courage.
In that I agree with patent.
I have known many officers who were physically brave,
but who did not have the intestinal fortitude to organize the chaos around them.
Those officers who were the most vocal about what they were going to do to the
enemy often were the first to fall apart when the chips were down.
Fear is not only debilitating,
but its existence also destroys the cohesion of a command.
It is the responsibility of a commander to identify the limits of courage,
break the paralysis of fear,
and motivate his soldiers to continue with the mission.
Courage conquers fear.
I liked just that,
that part,
and I don't think I did this.
And Helmet for my pillow,
doors a and helmet for my pillow that I pulled out when I was talking to one of
my seal buddies and I was cause he listened to it.
He said,
yeah,
yeah.
And I was telling him this one part that I didn't put in the podcast and I sent
him a picture of from the book,
this little paragraph,
but it's basically one of the instructors.
One of the drill instructors was all yelling about orbit to kill and Blah Blah
Blah.
And then he says,
yeah,
the next time I saw him we were in,
you know,
on island in the fight.
And he was getting taken away of br after breaking down.
Okay.
So this is what he's saying here.
A lot of guys that are the loudest about what they're going to do to the enemy.
Yeah.
Okay.
You're talking a big game,
you know,
but what's really good that happened.
You know what else that happens?
UFC
MMA,
it happens.
Yeah.
I'm going to kick off with a crush.
That guy and the other guy's sitting there going,
okay,
bring it.
Or He's in the locker room,
like explaining,
tell his teammates,
yeah,
I'll just,
I'm going to do this and I'm going to do that.
And it's almost like,
yeah,
it's weird trying to,
they're trying to convince them cause that's some solid.
So that's what,
that's what's going on here.
Same thing,
right.
Somebody who's trying to convince themselves they're not confident in
themselves.
Back to the book.
I suspect every soldier at one time or another experiences a degree of fear.
Courage is not the absence of fear,
but rather the willingness to rise above fear and do the things you know need to
be accomplished.
All soldiers hope that they will measure up the first time they get into a
fight.
I certainly was no exception,
but I believe I had prepared myself very well that once I came under fire,
I knew instinctively what needed to be done.
I think I was more apprehensive,
particularly before d day.
Then I was afraid.
Maybe apprehension is the first stage of fear.
I'm not really sure.
You have to remember that easy company was needly unit as we're all
paratroopers.
We had trained for nearly two years before we jumped into Normandy.
I think I saw far more excitement in the eyes of my men than I did fear after
break court.
We felt as if we were seasoned veterans even though we knew worst days were
ahead.
Yeah,
that apprehension and definitely my first deployment to Iraq.
When you had all these guys,
Bro,
the guys were so fired up to get it,
to do real missions and get after it that I think it was much more excitement
that it was fear,
especially in the beginning and it'd be getting,
you know,
there wasn't a lot of casualties going on.
We are kind of dominating and you know,
even showing up to Ramadi,
same thing.
Guys were like,
sign me up,
what mission I'm going.
And the more you spend time in that,
the more you realize what the threat is and you start losing.
Guys are having guys getting wounded.
That's when you start saying,
okay,
wait a second.
I'm not sure I want to die today.
And then guys got to overcome that.
And on a daily basis,
speaking of fierce,
Steve Ambross,
who's a military historian,
rent bunch of books including band of brothers,
Steve,
Steve Ambrose says that heavy artillery bombardment will make even the most
seasoned veteran eventually break.
I disagree.
A leader has to overcome fear,
convince himself that every enemy,
shell or bullet is not targeting him.
The same is true in a company or a battalion leaders.
Must ensure that strengthened cohesion is a stronger force than fear.
This is especially true in men who have been scarred by prolonged combat.
Ambrose was correct when he titled the Chapter Band of Br in band of brothers
breaking point as he describes the horrendous artillery barrage that inflicted
so many casualties on easy company in the boy's shocks company strength was
below 50% and many of the noncommissioned officers were killed or wounded
without direct supervision by leaders.
Easy company as well as the remainder of the battalion could have easily been
dipped,
debilitated by an increased sense of morality and fear.
That is precisely why I made it a point to visit the front lines as often as
possible.
Soldiers need to sense need a sense that their leaders and commanders are in the
game with them.
Leadership by example is even more important in these situations.
I noticed that when men are at the edge of their physical endurance,
you tend to develop that 1000 yard stare that you always read about.
Tired soldiers will often take off their helmet and run their fingers through
their hair.
We talked about that before and I talk about that quite often now.
At times they literally dropped their helmets on the ground.
This soldier is already losing his self respect.
The battle is half lost.
That's assigned for the commander to take immediate action.
I didn't wait for the trooper to reach that stage.
I proactively looked for these signs.
Every soldier wants to do the right thing.
You always know the proper thing to do,
but doing it is sometimes more difficult.
I never wanted a man to lose his self respect.
That's what I was talking about earlier,
this thing of self,
this idea of self respect when you don't care because you,
you know you could supposed to keep your gear on all the time.
That's like just the code,
right?
And keep your gear with you all the time to keep your gear and all the time.
The minute you take that off is where you start.
Hey,
I don't care what these guys think anymore.
Something has happened that has made you say,
you know what?
I don't care what these guys think anymore and that's not good.
Yeah.
And again,
this is such a contradiction because you know,
we can sit here and talk about like,
Hey,
I don't care what people think.
And I mean that.
I mean that you shouldn't care what people think,
but at the same time it should be extremely important to you what people think
and what your comrades think.
And that's such a weird dichotomy.
I don't think I've fully wrapped my hands around how to describe yet and what
that means.
I'll get there eventually,
hopefully.
Sure.
But,
but that is a very important thing and I've always felt like I don't care what
people think,
but at the same time I deeply care what my peers think and my,
my men think weird dichotomy.
I think that's a core value thing.
It's like you have these core values and that's what you care about.
You know what you think about it when everyone else thinks about it.
And then anything beyond that is just superficial fluff.
Like if you don't match your socks,
I,
I think what the key principle here are the,
the part that may help bring this together for me is I want to be doing the
right thing.
Yeah.
Right.
And so if I'm doing the right thing and people say,
Oh,
Jack was,
you know,
that's,
that's stupid what Jack was doing.
Or he shouldn't be doing that.
But I know in my heart I'm doing the right thing.
Yeah.
I'm going to continue to do and I don't care what you think.
There you go.
But at the same time,
if I know I'm doing the right thing and other people are,
are judging me,
that's going to keep me in line.
If I,
let me,
let me rephrase that.
If I feel like I'm going to do the wrong thing,
I do care what people think and I don't want them to think all Jockos getting
weak,
getting soft,
getting,
you know,
whatever he's doing the wrong thing.
He's making the wrong move.
Very strange.
That's the,
that's the dichotomy of leadership,
right?
Or one of them actually,
it's not really the dichotomy of leadership.
That's just a,
that's just the dichotomy in life life.
Yeah.
Now there's a,
a guy named lieutenant Compton who kind of breaks a little bit and they show it
in the,
in the band of brothers movie and they,
he,
Dick winters talks about it here.
Back to the book.
Before you go on,
I know you think I'm too hard on lieutenant comp and for walking off the line of
Bastogne.
My may explain myself buck.
That's the tenant competent was nicknamed buck and he walked,
walked off the line.
Buck was a great combat leader.
He was a superb platoon leader in Normandy and Holland.
In fact,
I would say he was one of the best at Bastogne.
He broke after some of his friends were seriously wounded in the constant
artillery barrages.
There is a danger of getting too close to the men and buck cross that line.
When you see your friends getting maimed,
it makes it more difficult to go on.
That's why I always maintained a certain detachment from the paratroopers and
easy company.
Am I too harsh on buck?
Maybe,
but of leader needs to rise above fear.
The easiest thing to do is quit
and then the author asks her,
why didn't you crack and Dick winters responses.
Um,
Pennsylvania,
Dutch,
I don't quit.
I made a commitment.
Moral courage is based on physical fitness.
Courage is a combination of willpower and determination and determination.
I was an excellent physical shape.
I don't think there was a man in the hour,
that outfit who's in better shape than I was and it showed I had trained hard in
England.
After we finished training.
I would run at night blackout conditions,
but I would run.
Then I'd come in and go to bed.
I was in maximum shape.
That was the physical side of things.
But there is a mental aspect of stamina as well.
I've always prided myself that I do my own thinking.
I have my own philosophy.
I have my own answers to the reasons things have turned out in my life by taking
full accountability,
accountability for my life,
I've been able to meet the standards that I set for myself.
I don't know any other way of saying it.
Okay.
Every commander must take full accountability for his actions.
Stand up and be counted as a commander.
You are accountable for everything that your outfit does or fails to do.
Don't worry about who receives credit when things go well.
Don't play the blame game.
In my case,
the mantle of command provided me with the courage to succeed.
Yeah,
extreme ownership.
That's what he's talking about,
you know,
personal accountability.
That's what he's talking about being in great physical condition.
That's what he's talking about.
That's discipline.
You know,
I guess as we read this,
and I and I,
you know I didn't read this book until
a week ago,
a week ago.
I read this book,
so it's not like I read this book and said,
Hey,
personal accountability is the most important thing about,
you know,
being a leader.
No,
this is guy came to the same conclusion in World War II that I came to and
conclusion and my experience in the military.
Yeah.
Now he starts talking a little bit about combat fatigue.
How much combat fatigue there was enormous.
I witnessed lots of stress,
some in Holland,
much more in Bastogne due to the intense cold lack of sleep and inadequate
clothing.
In Belgium.
Combat Fatigue reached astronomical proportions.
We'd spent 70 days in the front lines in Holland and didn't have time to recover
before we boarded the trucks to take us to Bastogne.
On reflection,
I realized what was happening.
What happened.
By the time the command arrived at Bastogne,
the men had been on the front lines.
Since Normandy,
men were exhausted,
no hot food,
little sleep,
no rest,
constant tension and intense pressure from combat.
They were physically exhausted.
Inclement weather and constant rain and snow made matters even worse.
Physical exhaustion leads to mental exhaustion,
which in turn causes men to lose discipline.
The loss of self discipline produces combat fatigue
over and over again.
Over and over again.
We hear that.
How important is discipline?
It is the most important thing.
Okay,
and if,
if discipline is what gets people through these situations,
through combat stress,
through tension,
through bombs,
through artillery,
through freezing cold,
lack of food,
lack of sleep.
Imagine what discipline can do in like a normal person's life.
Yeah.
Back to the book.
How can you possibly compare a man who's been under just one concentrated
artillery bombardment for five minutes to a place like Bastogne where he could
be in the line for weeks or months in one of Ambrose books,
he states that prolonged artillery bombardment will break any soldier.
Okay.
In civilian life,
of course we refer to combat fatigue as a mental breakdown.
That is exactly the way it is in combat.
It's a mental breakdown,
the intensity,
it becomes a problem for me to express my feelings here,
but I'd like to share it with you.
The intensity of a fire or a heavy concentration.
To be a leader,
you have to be able to concentrate on that fire and move just as soon as it
stops or the last rounds hit move,
get up,
start circulating among your men.
Is everybody okay?
Let's get up,
let's move.
Keep your eye open for an attack,
get their attention,
move among your med as quickly as possible and moving among them.
The fact that they see you and they're talking to you,
they know that you are there and you are talking to them and it makes all the
difference in the world to know that you are not in this thing by yourself,
okay?
That's what officers must do.
Break the cycle of fear,
okay?
If a soldier is concentrating on his own feelings and on his own fear and he
sees you moving around,
he realizes that you're sharing the burden with him,
okay?
That's why he can then move.
So that's a very important and that's,
you know,
again,
that can apply to combat.
That could bought a business.
People are going to start panicking.
What are they going to do when they start panicking?
You and the leader as the leader need to step up.
Get out there,
talk to people,
find out what's going on.
Tell him that we're going to move.
You do.
Show them that you're not afraid and that you are afraid,
but you're still functioning.
Lead by example.
Plain and simple.
Back to the book.
Courage will be spent.
If you relax your standards and undisciplined soldier feels isolated and alone.
Maintain the standards.
Don't compromise your integrity,
never get up.
Give Up.
Don't ever give up.
I love this right here.
There is always one more that a leader can do to improve his situation and that
of his command.
I always felt that a leader's physical presence was indispensable to unit
cohesion and morale.
This is why I've captain,
so bell failed so miserably.
Leadership by example always trumps leadership by fear.
There's always one more thing that a leader can do to improve his situation and
that of his command is always one more thing you can do,
and an undisciplined soldier feels isolated and alone.
Okay?
They know they've given up that self respect.
How are you going to give it back to him?
Hmm?
When your men are dying and you do not,
you feel ashamed.
I don't know any other way of saying it.
Soldiers in war,
certainly in world war two and I suspect in every war are generally young men in
their prime.
They meet death daily and in every form
they fully realize the hazards of their profession.
They take chances because no young man expects to die before middle age.
When the first soldier dies,
that belief in immortality is shattered.
As casualties mount and the core of the unit grows fewer.
The remaining soldiers grow even stronger,
often shutting off replacement soldiers.
They don't want to know the replacements because they are often the first to
die.
Okay?
When I saw one of my men wounded,
I was happy that he had a ticket home,
a soldier killed in battle.
Was it peace?
He had lived his life among men whom he had loved.
I took a degree of constellation and knowing that my men had lived rather than
regretting that they had died,
uh,
soldiers,
real fear is not losing his life in combat,
but placing his comrades in jeopardy.
That's why ordinary men were performing in extraordinary ways to ensure that
their buddies survive.
Okay?
So this is another level of
war when you're actually,
and I'd never was at this point by any stretch where you're looking at men that
get wounded in St Oh,
lucky him.
He's got to take it home.
We just weren't under that neath that kind of casualty level
at all.
So when guys were getting wounded,
it was,
you know,
it was hard.
It was,
you didn't feel like cook all about lucky him.
He's got to take it home because there wasn't enough guys getting wounded to
make you think that way and not enough guys getting killed to make you think
that way.
Small percentage.
Yeah.
That's as reaching a whole new level
back to the book.
If you've selected the right personnel,
then a leader must instill discipline.
I mean,
perfect discipline as patent once said,
discipline is the soul of the army.
Okay.
General Washington said the same thing when he described the continental army in
1776 discipline is manifested in how well a soldier keeps his uniform.
Okay.
How frequently he cleans his weapon and the pride he has in his unit.
Joe Hogan of easy company speaks for all of us on the subject of pride in
company e during an argument with a soldier from another company about whose
company was better.
Joe Said,
my company,
he will lick your company in 15 minutes and if you wait until the guys who are
AWOL come back,
we'll do it in five minutes.
And this is important.
Unit pride leads to unit discipline.
Okay,
so again,
now we're going back to the feelings that I had when I was a young kid in the
seal teams.
I get it.
Pride in Michael Tune.
And this is funny cause you just say,
I'm like,
look,
the guys that are gone right now,
they're a Walter absent without leave.
If they give you wait for them to come back,
we'll be getting this done in five minutes.
But you know,
I feel like this,
this unit pride and unit discipline,
how they go together.
It's like a gang.
I don't know why I think of it this way and I talked about this,
the monster.
It's like a gang mentality when you start policing yourself up,
right?
Yeah.
When we,
when I was in a school platoon we,
it wasn't our bosses that were,
we're trying to keep us in line.
We kept ourselves in line.
You didn't want to get out of the side.
You didn't want to do something wrong because we you're going to get policed up
by the boys.
The e five mafia is what we work,
so the e five mafia,
that's a real thing by the way,
the e five mafia in a seal platoon,
you got the senior guys who's like the the platoon,
the platoon chief,
the leading petty officer.
Those are,
those are like [inaudible] seven and you've got the assistant platoon commander.
Those,
those are like the,
they call them the top four.
Those are the guys that kind of run the actual leadership and then you got the
nugs and then in the middle of the pack right there you've got the [inaudible].
They're the guys that are actually running things and making things happen and
the e five mafia is what we call them and then in a is [inaudible] e five mafia
and all works together to make things happen.
But with the e five mafia,
if you've got a good unit,
that e five mafia,
they're policing up everything and you don't need to,
as a leader,
you just need to make sure that they don't take it too far is the only thing you
need to make sure,
but they're going to,
they're going to make sure guys are doing the right thing.
They're going to make sure that they're performing well,
they're gonna make sure that they're in good shape,
they're going to make sure I'm all those things.
Hmm.
And this was an interesting quote.
What you tolerate,
you can dome,
so again,
extreme ownership written by myself and Lafe,
Bab and wildlife,
Bab and wrote a line in there.
It says,
it's not what you preach,
it's what you tolerate and he hadn't read this book and here it is.
What you tolerate.
You can donate to saying the exact same thing.
If you knew,
let standards start to slide you.
That's what you're done.
That's the new standard.
Yeah,
of course.
There's a little bit more to leadership than what we've talked about so far.
Back to the book.
Leading in battle is the art of dealing with human nature and the human
condition.
I can't speak of higher command,
but I know a few things about leadership.
At the small unit level.
Leadership at all levels wins wars,
but soldiers at the platoon,
company and battalion levels when battles,
I think this is particularly true in the national army were soldiers need to
understand the reasons behind the officer's orders.
We have to know why we're doing what we're doing.
Would I have succeeded?
Had I been promoted beyond battalion?
I don't know.
I do know that I felt comfortable at the small unit level.
This is one reason why easy company holds such a tender place in my heart.
I knew the strengths and weaknesses of every paratrooper.
I could rapidly ascertain what I wanted to do and felt confident that I could
convince the men to do it.
After commanding easy company in Normandy and Holland,
I know that the men felt comfortable and trusting their lives to my care.
Okay.
I'm not bragging because it's not my nature to do so.
I'm stating fact knowing that I would never ask them to do anything that I
wouldn't do myself.
Led to easy companies,
confidence in me as a leader.
Okay.
They knew that I would never quit and then I would do everything within my power
to bring them home after the war.
I'm proud when I hear a paratrooper from easy company,
your second battalion remark about my courage under fire and my willingness to
share their hardships.
I told you once that wars do not make great men.
Yeah,
but war sometimes bring out the greatness in good men,
human nature.
That's what it is.
And you know that's sorta how I described this podcast.
Now,
an exploration of human nature and if you want to see human nature reveal itself
and its most clearest form,
you have to go to war to look at that or others.
Very strenuous situations,
harsh situations
upon returning from the war.
Here's what major winters had to say back to the book.
The war changed me.
I returned to the states bitter.
Okay.
A different man than the young man who had enlisted in the army in 1941 I was
hardened when I returned.
First impressions were more important than they had previously been.
I looked at things differently.
Okay.
When you returned from a wartime environment,
you have to adjust to society,
the life that you are going to be sharing with others just to make a living.
Though I was comfortable in a combat environment,
I wondered if I would feel at home among civilized people who wouldn't be able
to understand how a soldier thinks and feels.
I came to understand that I would have to make changes to be accepted into life
at home.
This takes time and it's never easy.
While we're on the front lines and prolonged combat.
I often wondered about my friends back in the states,
old friends I had grown up with some of whom had avoided coming over either by
becoming conscience as objectors or working in Warren Leight related factories
that the federal government had declared essential.
Yeah,
I understand.
Everyone doesn't have to share my belief that military service is the only form
of service in war time,
but I took immense pride in my contribution to the war effort.
We who fought the war were part of something noble.
Okay.
Military service is an honor.
A privilege.
Funny thing is that when I finally returned home,
I had no desire to pick up with those friends who managed to skip the whole
thing.
Okay.
I completely shut them out.
I wouldn't come downstairs when they knocked on the door.
Even today,
when I look at a man or a woman,
I can't help but judge them.
Okay.
Does he have leadership capabilities?
Would she be good in combat?
Does he or she have what it takes?
Okay.
And I think you know clearly
right
when you come home,
those are things I think everybody goes through of,
you're looking at people,
you're kind of judging people.
It certainly will leave a mark.
I,
I'll tell you,
I don't think there's enough veterans now.
You know,
you're not gonna be able to just hang around with veterans.
It's not going to happen.
You got to,
you got to understand and accept the fact that not everyone served the way you
served.
That's just the way it is and
I don't,
I try to make sure that I eat don't outwardly hold people to a higher
expectation.
Any other thing is,
I think you have to walk a fine line and you got to make sure you're not looking
down on people because they didn't choose the path that you chose.
Now World War II was different cause or at least appears to be different because
it was so easy.
So many people went on the path of,
okay,
you know,
December 7th happened,
I'm going to sign up tomorrow,
today,
whatever.
And I think that the way these wars that we've been fighting have gone down,
it hasn't been the same.
It's been different and I think we,
veterans right now have to use some caution before just shutting out everyone
else at that didn't serve the way we did.
We'd be shutting out basically.
You probably be shutting out most of the people in your lives.
Most,
most of my friends outside the seal teams there,
you know Jujitsu.
I've got a bunch of friends from Jujitsu,
none of them served.
I can't just shut them all out,
so I think we have to be careful about that as as veterans to make sure we
you're going to have those feelings.
Understood.
Understand that there's more than that and you got to,
you got to accept other things going on in the world besides a what we did
another letter that
Dick Winters wrote to d Allman.
Going back to the book,
when you're an officer,
you are responsible for the lives of soldiers in your command.
You think about kids like this one pair of trooper.
I knew well and you soon become old beyond your years.
In the three years since I had entered the army,
I aged a great deal.
Yeah.
It seems as if college days and days of civilian life when I did as I pleased
are long past,
I must've been,
it must have been a dream,
a small and short,
but beautiful part of my life.
Now,
all I do is work,
work to improve myself as an officer,
work to improve them as fighters,
as men,
make them work to improve themselves.
The result is I am old before my time,
not physically old,
but hardened to the point where I can make the rest of them look like
undeveloped high school boys old to the extent where I can keep going after my
men fall over and sleep from exhaustion.
Okay,
I can keep going.
As a mother who works after her sick child and exhausted child has fallen asleep
old to the extent where if it's a decision or advice needed,
my decisions are taken as if the wisdom behind them was infallible.
Okay?
Yes.
I feel old and tired from training these men to the point where they are
efficient fighters.
I hope it means
that some will return to those girls back home.
And again,
the reason I put that in there is because there's,
that's pressure,
right?
That's the certain amount of pressure that a person that's been in the military
has felt and
it's real.
That pressure
and his wife said,
Dick fights the battle of the bulge of virtually every night.
He had recurring nightmares.
So even dick winters,
you know,
a very thoughtful and squared away guy was still living those nightmares
virtually every night.
His wife said,
Dick also said back to the book,
I know I did everything within my power to ensure as many soldiers made it home
from the war as possible.
But when you survive and your soldiers don't,
yeah,
you feel guilty.
It haunts me to this day that I lived and so many of my paratroopers died
as the veterans of easy company pass on.
I reminded of those who never returned from the war.
I see their faces.
I can almost hear them calling me
good again.
I think that everybody that's served
and survived when your friends and your brothers didn't,
you're always going to have that.
It's not going to go away.
And Dick Winters,
Major Dick winters died January 2nd,
obviously they had a memorial service,
the big memorial service for him back to the book.
Those who remained alive voiced their sympathy,
said former platoon sergeant William Gardner who had lost a leg outside Bastogne
Dick always said,
hang tough.
Follow me
when he said let's go.
He was right in the front.
Okay.
He was never in the back.
A leader personified.
He was the best commander we ever had.
Okay.
We'd have followed him anywhere.
Edward Babe Heffernan who served alongside winners at Bastogne and who helped
liberate Hitler's Eagle's nest added.
He was one hell of a guy,
one of the greatest soldiers I ever was under.
He was a wonderful officer,
a wonderful leader.
He had what you needed.
Guts and brains.
Yeah.
He took care of his men.
That's very important.
Pop by when added,
it seemed as if you always made the right decision.
He was a real soldier.
He was one of the best.
Okay.
It started with him doing the right thing.
I don't know how he survived the war,
but he did
another easy company veteran concurred noting every one of us.
We'd follow him to hell.
That's the type of guy he was.
And also speaking at that ceremony was a guy by the name of Eric jury gendered
person who is the screenwriter or one of the screenwriters for band of brothers.
Okay.
And he was trying to get the screenplay and the series to be as accurate as
possible.
And so he spent a lot of time with Dick winters and he got to know him very well
and I found what he said about Dick winters to be very important.
Here we go back to the book,
Dick Winters made it his personal quest to excel,
whether it was executing the perfect pushup or training himself to run three
miles up and down Kerr he mountain.
This pursuit was his private tool is solution.
And it was that solo effort,
that obsessive clarity and pure determined self contained purpose that is met,
observed and that caused them to follow.
When he said,
simply follow me.
Okay,
not just through that hedge row in Normandy and across that field and Holland
under enemy fire,
but follow my example,
follow my commitment
and we'll get through this.
Okay,
then we will succeed.
Dick winters was laid to rest in his family plot
in the Evangelical Lutheran cemetery in the Frat up Pennsylvania,
the Saturday following his death.
It his gravestone,
read simply
Richard Di Winters,
World War 201st airborne
1918 to 2011
and Dick winters before he died said,
I am the man I am today because of easy company,
easy company made me as I reflect upon my life since the war.
I can honestly say that it has been a lifetime search for men.
Like those I knew an easy company.
I haven't found too many,
I don't think I know brave or soldiers than Joe Toy.
They'll go onto your fluid.
Talbert.
I live with these guys every day.
I mourn when they pass Carwood lipped and died in December,
2001 his death struck me particularly hard.
So did bull ramble mints.
Lipton didn't live to see the acclaim easy company received when the mini series
was released.
I try not to think of the bad times anymore.
I think mostly of the good times,
the emotion will always be there
and
no Dick Winters said that war brings out greatness and men
and he also realized that war makes you appreciate
your country.
The major winners before he died said,
well,
it probably sounds strange to you,
but when I brought easy company to Utah Beach so we could board the lst to
return to England on July 11th,
1944 I saw that beach for the first time with that vast armada of ships as far
as the eye could see in every direction.
Seeing the American flag fluttering over that beach,
I felt weak in the knees and tears filled my eyes.
Suddenly that flag meant something different than it ever had before.
I've never looked at our flag since without that memory in mind.
Now I'm an old man,
but that feeling has never left me
and finally
then I always say
that war is awful
in war is a nightmare,
but war does certainly make you appreciate life
and Dick winters certainly appreciated the rest of his life.
Then he said this,
I sit here in this house and I gaze out the window.
Okay,
I see flowers and the birds
I'd be hold the wonder of nature,
everything seems okay.
So beautiful.
That wraps up that book.
Everything seems so beautiful.
And you know,
over the past couple of weeks
I've been traveling a bunch and meeting a lot of different people.
Business people,
workers,
okay.
Police and firefighters and active duty military and veterans,
just people.
And we,
we get caught up in all kinds of chaos and mayhem
may him from the past.
We get caught up in that about what we should have done
or what we should have left undone.
And we feel this pressure about the future,
about what we should do or what we shouldn't do or where we're going and how we
should get there.
And I get that.
I get that,
I understand it.
I feel it too.
The life is hard.
Life is hard.
And if you weren't careful,
it will grind you down.
And you know,
I talk about detachment a lot from a leadership perspective and we talked about
today and it's certainly important,
but it's also a tool
for your mind
and for your sanity.
Step back,
step back and look around
not just to see what your next move is and where to head next and what to focus
on,
but to step back,
to look around and,
and sea life.
This life,
your life,
not surrounded by the pressure and the war and the failures and the violence and
the nightmares and the mistakes and the grind.
Not that life,
but life as it is
as it is without our intervention,
a blessing,
a journey,
a short little bit of time on an incredibly fast moving sphere of amazement.
Where if you can detach
and step back and look for a moment,
you'll see
that like Dick Winterset,
everything seems
so beautiful.
And I think that's
all I've got for tonight.
So Echo Charles.
Yeah,
some lessons.
very impactful
for me in a big reminder for me,
we,
we worked heavily with the first of the five oh six band of brothers in the
battle of Ramadi.
We had,
uh,
the Delta platoon commander and a group of his guys spent the whole time over
there and what an incredible bunch of soldiers.
They were just incredible.
The impact that they had on the battlefield,
the leadership I saw at every level level.
And whenever I think of the band of brothers,
my first thoughts when I think in the band of brothers isn't about Dick Winters.
It isn't about the series,
it isn't about the books.
My first thought of the band of brothers is the first of the five Oh six
battalion that we were honored to work with in the battle Ramadi and one of my
platoons worked intensely with the entire time.
And so for their service and sacrifice,
we w I am eternally thankful for what they did and what they taught us.
And for us,
being alongside them was a real humbling,
real humbling.
Yeah.
You mentioned how,
how like
in all these books and all these lessons that discipline is like so important
and there was time you mentioned like imagine or imagine how important it is or
how beneficial,
whatever it could be just in everyday life.
I remember that.
Yeah,
that's,
that's crazy.
In the more books like this that we go over,
whatever that message like becomes more and more clear because you know how like
you get 'em like creative guys,
you know,
but they don't have discipline kind of thing.
Or you get super disciplined guys but they don't have creativity or you know,
kind of.
But every once in a while you'll get,
you'll find a person or you'll notice a person who does bring them together,
you know,
and you see the results.
Like you see what kind of productivity or you just,
you just see the results in one way or another.
You know,
like these get like fighters or,
you know,
I don't know,
author like anyone.
Anyone.
Absolutely.
So,
uh,
man,
it's crazy how,
because even if you're like naturally gifted or whatever at something you in a
way that's really cool.
I don't know what that's like,
but I mean it,
let's say you notice someone and you see it in,
in all these different fields as well,
or where,
oh,
someone that's got a lot of natural talent.
Yeah.
But then don't,
they don't have to because essentially through upbringing or whatever,
that just their environment,
they don't need it really.
You know,
they don't need it.
Like just get away with it.
Cause that's just one of their talent.
They get away with it.
Yes,
exactly what I mean,
I mean
I think we hear that a lot.
This idea that,
you know,
talent,
it doesn't mean anything if you don't have the discipline to make things happen.
And I'm a person that's highly disciplined,
will outperform
someone that might be more talented all day long,
all day long.
Yeah.
It was all day long.
Too strong as you had in the beginning,
in the beginning.
And I think,
yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
I feel like eventually,
um,
the discipline is the thing that's just going to carry you through.
So,
and I thought,
I just thought that was super important where you were like,
imagine if this,
if you apply this to everyday life because everyday life essentially for us
anyway,
it's like a straight up luxury.
Yeah,
it is.
And here's what's important about what you're saying is,
is this fact that the reason that these guys had to have discipline was cause if
they didn't have discipline,
they would die.
Yeah.
If they didn't have discipline,
they would be overrun.
they would get,
they would starve.
They would just die.
They would die.
So they have to have discipline.
And your point is in this world and this life in 2017 living in the first world,
you don't have to have discipline at all and you'll still survive and you might
even do okay.
Yeah,
sure.
I mean just imagine,
just imagine if you applied the discipline to your life where you'll end up and
how much better off you'll be and how much more you can do with your life.
The OneLife you have,
by the way,
how much the more you can do with that life,
if you just have the discipline and work hard and get after it and you see it in
little pockets to like,
remember when you're a kid and you're like,
I'm going to save,
save my money for this.
I Dunno.
Comic Book,
I duNNo,
I'm gonna Save my money.
You don't even have an income by the way,
but somehow you save all your money.
Like that little corridor that you find that's an old,
you know,
I'm going to save that.
I'm going to save that because you have this kind of,
and in a way like the discipline kind of forms itself around that goal.
So you know what it is like,
you know what that means,
you know?
So it's real.
Like that's a real thing.
You shouldn't,
you shouldn't be regarded as some ambiguous thing.
That other fancy,
crazy thing at all.
Yeah.
It's a real straightforward,
yeah.
I think,
I think that was one of the first podcast,
if we did where I said something along the lines of like,
you know what you need to do.
Yeah.
The look we all know do it should be doing,
I think that one of the first,
there's not too many people that are lost that are going on.
I'm just not sure how to do this.
No.
They know exactly what we know exactly what do I know exactly what I should be
doing.
Tell you what it is.
Distractions.
It's too many.
Distractions and distractions are literally everything.
There's industries of just distractions.
That's the whole industry like TV,
TV,
history of distract.
Huge.
And the in the defense of TV,
TV can be edgy.
Yeah,
you can cause there's educational stuff on TV.
Um,
defendant,
I'm just saying like Cedar Point,
the entertainment industry and I'm not saying these industries have distractions
are bad things.
I'm not saying that I'm just saying distractions or what gets in the way of,
I don't know,
for lack of a better term.
Like your your goal.
Yeah.
And
well we're talking about the very fact of some of your discipline can be used to
create things that are actually distracting.
I mean if you want,
if your goal is to create some artistic piece,
whether it's a movie,
whether it's music,
whether it's whatever.
Yeah.
That,
that's a distracting thing.
But that's not,
that doesn't mean that it's negative that you want to make that happen because
there's people that'll find something.
I mean the reason you want to create something is I guess you create it for
yourself.
But then the reward is when other people say,
yes,
I get something out.
Recognition from your peers.
Yeah,
for sure.
and when I say distractions,
I W W in regards to goal,
it's a relative thing.
Meaning like you're distracted from your path of the goal.
I agree with you.
Yeah.
But there's also just just mentally,
just just weakness.
Just the easy path I should say.
The discipline plans is hard.
The the the easy path that anyone wants to jump on when your alarm clock goes
off,
blah,
blah.
Right.
I've talked about these things a million times.
That's what the problem is.
The problem isn't even a distraction.
The problem is just the lack of will to do what you need to do.
Right.
It's a distraction.
Can add to that.
That's a,
that's a part of it.
What we do is we take,
we take are the path of least resistance and then we throw distraction on top of
that.
For instance,
when you open up your computer cause you've got to write a book and instead of
opening the word process you call,
I'm just going to check the interwebs real quick.
Distracted.
Yeah,
you're distracted.
There goes 45 minutes,
you have a taser.
See flooding the Internet is the Internet is a mind,
a time warp.
Oh at and time just disappears in the Internet.
There's a lot of distractions on there for sure.
And really what I mean by destruction is you have this longterm goal,
right?
Your goal is your payoff,
your longterm payoff though.
So the distractions really are these little short term payoff that drag you,
that dis track you.
So that's what gets us through the destruction.
And you broke that out for me plus cause you off the track.
Exactly right.
So the weakness will let those distractions kind of take hold for sure.
But so yeah they work hand in hand for sure.
So so if you can see,
cause again that saving money for comic books thing.
So consider that as the goal.
So the distractions are going to be the candy that you want to buy or the,
you know,
I don't know.
You play dice with your for,
I dunno,
whatever the distractions is in regards to that specific pack.
I like echoes world right now.
Playing dice with your friends.
Saving for comic books.
It's like 1956 I like it.
But either way,
like the distraction there are relative.
So when I say,
okay,
the distractions are there.
When I say there's industries of distractions,
again,
I'm not saying those are bad things.
They are bad things.
If they're distracting you from your goal so you get out.
It's true.
Think about it.
Sometimes you just need to let your mind take a rest.
Yeah,
filling the need.
One of the game,
I just flew home from like I've been on the road,
we're all over the world.
Did the monster,
did a bunch of speeches,
did some consulting and it was all over the place on a plane the whole time.
And I flew home from the east coast.
When was that set?
A couple of days ago.
And when I haven't done this in forever.
I flew home,
I watched a movie.
I just did a total distraction cause I said,
you know what?
I can't,
I'm not,
I,
I'm not in the game right now.
Like I need,
my brain just needs to shut off and do something,
which I don't like to do,
which is you can either do two things.
I look at it,
you can either consume or you can produce,
right?
I want to be producing,
I want to be putting together,
I want to be writing,
I want to be thinking,
reading for the podcast,
prepping.
That's what I want to be doing.
Only producing something consuming is I'm just absorbing what someone else made.
Right?
I'm just going to absorb this,
absorb this,
absorb this.
A lot of times it is garbage.
So I,
but I flew home,
had a long flight and I was like,
you know what?
I need to check out.
I need to check out right now and just do nothing.
So I watched two movies,
dig it to move.
You got to go.
The two movies I watched.
The first one was
not heartbreak ridge.
It's the new movie that just came out
about dos that Mel Gibson directed,
what's it called?
I Dunno.
There's a big successful movie conscious objector,
World War II.
He wins the medal of honor or he's awarded the Medal of honor.
So that was a good movie.
And you know it's a World War II movie.
I liked it.
It's not in my opinion five star.
But it was good.
It was entertaining.
Sure.
It told the story.
And then after that I watched
zoo lander.
That was what I was going into a full decompression mode.
Good [inaudible] lender because it's a hilarious movie.
I have a buddy in the teams that we nicknamed Moo.
Got To sure.
Yeah.
Cause you know he would go crazy.
So we had to call [inaudible] and yeah,
that was just a funny,
where we had just decompressed and I don't do that very often.
The grind is always happening.
I just had to take a little detachment.
What was the name of that movie with?
There's not a famous actors,
I guess there's one who's a really funny guy anyways.
It's a good movie.
Yeah.
So techno what the,
so the question is,
is that really a distraction?
So you know,
like a football game or a movie or something that,
that you're not doing to put you more forward on your path or whatever.
But if you're taking your,
if you're taking a break,
is that a distraction?
Like if I'm lifting,
I do a workout and then I go recover from that word or recipes that a district,
it wasn't a distraction.
Right.
I should have grinded though.
No,
I'm just kidding.
I was done.
So tapped out.
So distraction is more of an idea,
more of the concept,
you know,
so like it's definitely things that are just like how you said when you open
your computer and the whole Internet is there to distract him one way or
another.
That's a distraction.
You know,
where you can eat.
Like,
even if I have a book,
if my goal is to finish some video,
but meanwhile I have this book that's really informative and you know something
and I'm like,
you know,
oh,
that book seems real.
I'm real in the mood to read that book.
That's a distraction even though it's a good thing,
you know?
So the distraction is like the idea.
So you know,
what are the common goals?
I want to get in shape.
I want to,
um,
you know,
be a better husband or wife or I want to do better at work on a learn more.
I want to read all this stuff.
You're better at Jujitsu,
get better at digital,
all this stuff.
You can get distracted by these other things.
You know,
before I,
I don't know,
read,
I'm going to surf Instagram or something like that.
That's a distraction,
you know?
And now,
which was my original point is the reason,
or one of the reasons that we don't apply this extreme discipline as it's
outlined in these books here is B is one of the reasons is because we have
literally infinite amount of distraction.
No,
there's also no consequence,
or I shouldn't say that.
The consequence isn't visible consequences.
You don't say,
you don't say,
Hey,
if I would have had discipline,
I would reach this ultimate potential.
You just okay with not reaching that ultimate potential and you're okay with
just like turning up,
putting microwaveable popcorn in and watching a movie.
Dude,
you've been doing it the whole time.
I'm still here.
Hey,
I'm good.
And you know what?
There was a good movie and a popcorn tastes good.
They all know what I mean.
That's the wrong answer.
You don't recognize what your potential is,
and so you're just okay with this kind of half potential.
You don't reach your potential and since you don't know it and the other thing,
it's hard to see.
It's hard to see how that long term affects you.
You know,
like,
Oh yes,
just one bag of popcorn is just one movie.
But he did that three times this week.
Yeah.
You know,
that's,
that's not good.
You 30 times,
you know,
in the,
in the past 10 weeks you could write 30,000 words.
No more than that.
You're going to have about thousand words an hour.
A good way to look at it.
And I think I might've said this where
it's not like a moment to moment looking to the future kind of thing.
You should look at it,
but um,
in the way of,
in the sense of looking at it in the past.
So let's say you consider the last one year or two years,
right?
And let's say I want it to play better guitar,
something good goal.
Yeah,
I have that goal.
I always fail at it.
There you go.
So you look at it in this way where you don't say,
okay,
if I spend an hour a day,
um,
you know,
practicing guitar and you know,
in a year I'll be better.
You don't necessarily look like that.
You can't.
But a good way to look at it or helpful with is if you look at it last year,
where,
Dang,
if I,
if I would have played in an hour a day right now,
I would,
right now as I'm sitting here with you right now,
I'd be,
that'd be dope.
It Guitar,
you know,
kind of like that.
So you kind of get the ball.
In my experience,
I've kind of got this feeling of like wasted time,
you know,
you know that feeling where it's like,
Dang,
I got to,
I got to play catch up now that's a little bit more compelling.
I think sometimes it can be.
So He's thinking about it that way too.
I think that helps.
I don't know,
maybe,
maybe not.
Speaking of help,
speaking of help and potential,
oh both nicely done.
Double Gravitational.
You need help by with supplementation if you're working out.
So man,
how you said you can't not work out.
I think especially nowadays like you because your life to probability wise is,
is,
is cruising.
You're cruising physically where you know,
you go to office because really that's what is physically easy,
right?
Easier and gets easier and easier.
Even if it's not easy right now,
next year,
generally speaking,
it's going to be easier.
You know,
like even like I'm brushing my teeth like I do every week or whatever and it's a
week whether or not.
And so I have the regular toothbrush,
you know,
I'm sure there's all kinds of little micro technologies in the toothbrush,
but I started to think,
man,
this there ha,
you know,
this is a old school thing.
There's automatic toothbrushes.
Actually my brother told me about this to split do this automatic,
you know,
electric toothbrush to hell.
It's like super dope.
And I highly recommended it.
It was like $89 all this stuff.
And I'm thinking,
Dang,
something as basic as brushing your teeth is way easier now.
Way Easier.
I've got a machine to do it.
That's,
that's really the whole narrative with everything point being physically pushed
yourself cause you're not going to have to push it.
You got to reiterate it.
Push you.
Yeah.
It,
your environment is,
is starting to work more and more against you in regards to physical activity.
So my point being,
you got to work out how I was going to say that's a real straight forward thing.
Workout.
Yeah.
But I feel like it's,
I mean it's easy for you,
you know,
to to be like,
yeah,
it seems obvious.
You know,
they call that the curse of knowledge.
You know how when you're,
you're like so advanced in this one thing that you forget how it is to not be
advanced.
The Chris have forgotten what it's like to not be advanced in terms of trying to
explain to people why they would,
but I think it's pretty self evident to anybody why you'd work out.
No,
you're wrong.
Yeah.
Okay.
Think about this.
And I think,
and I thought about this one.
Okay.
You don't,
when you go into a Jujitsu gym,
you're different.
So you may very well not even understand this.
This might not compute with you,
but if you walk into did you to the gym,
and this applies to even a regular 24 hour fitness gym.
If you've never been in there before,
it never worked out.
That's a really intimidating thing.
You come in,
everyone's looking at me.
I don't know how to use the machines.
I don't know how to work out.
Like everyone's looking at me judging me.
I'm dumb.
It is not my element.
All this stuff,
it's intimidating,
you know?
But it's real.
It's what I'm saying.
You know how you say it like you probably don't know about that because you
don't have the curse of knowledge in regards to like physical activity working
out,
you know all that stuff and then the pain that comes with it.
I man,
I dig it.
I understand,
but that's even more of a reason to work out
physical condition anyway.
You'll be glad you did.
If you don't work out,
just jump in there.
Jump in,
go to the gym last year if you would have started working out,
you know how dope you'd be right now.
Way doper than you are if in the event you didn't start less last year.
See what I'm saying?
Anyway,
while you work out,
your joints might be kind of sore.
I know this from experience.
Take Krill oil.
My father in law turned me onto it.
Actually technically didn't successfully lead.
Turn me onto it.
The total he tried,
he tried and you know I didn't see the light until Jocko turned me on to it.
So now I'm turning everyone else onto it.
Hopefully successfully a Krill oil is,
I'm not going to go into a whole deep thing here,
but it's for your joint,
so if you get joint pain,
we just,
with degeneration over time you get older it dig it.
It's Krill oil bring you back.
They'll function.
It's Kinda like your joint joint.
Certain like always warm now.
Not like to the touch warm,
but like I'm like ready for action.
You see what I'm saying?
Anyway,
Krill oil.
I ain't even say by who.
Huh?
If you don't know on it.
That's the whole company and they had,
they don't have just krill oil.
They have other stuff to duck.
Yeah,
performance stuff.
Sharon deck.
I recommend shroom tech by the way.
Big Time.
Especially if you're,
if you're going for performance.
Yeah.
If you're going to go train Jujitsu with Andy Taylor,
Dean Craig Baker,
Greg,
train echo.
Charles just take,
take the shrimp.
They know what sport shroom tech sport.
Take three of them.
Oh,
is that the front?
That's the recommended.
I didn't know that and then I read it.
I'm like one day I just read the instructions for no reason.
I was like,
I wonder if I take 12 of these things if I'm been into more tech.
But I did say three because I had been taken to a fro.
Sorry.
It took three.
It felt a little bit and legit.
Yeah.
I always take three and never let down.
And again,
that's for the performance.
So if I'm just cruising,
if I'm just taking a walk around the block or or two,
I take the shroom tech,
I'm not going to feel it as much as if I jump in.
Did you do three rounds?
You know?
Yeah.
No I take it when I have to perform a situation.
Big Time.
Me Too.
You take shroom tech immune not to be confused with and I've taken shroom tech
immune when I go massive travel,
just getting all these planes and all these people.
Everyone's sick,
coughing,
sneezing.
It's all nasty on,
you know what I do just go ahead and take some shroom tech immune.
It's something different cause it's yellowish.
The lady,
the labels green too.
So the um,
the whatever you're eating is more yellow.
Yeah,
I think the ingredients,
we'll just say the ingredients there.
You know,
I take vitamin C's,
a big travel,
vitamin C,
Trintech Tech Immune.
Here's zinc is a good one too.
This is what I hear.
I've taken zinc before to try and overcome a cold,
but I wasn't very uh,
you know,
convinced.
Yeah.
I can power our power some vitamin C though,
if I feel like some kind of a disease coming on power the vitamin C and that's
kind of the good thing where you take this,
um,
shroom tech immune.
Yeah.
Like you know,
you know that they were like,
okay,
does vitamin C help?
Okay.
Check it.
Does zinc in,
I don't know.
I didn't read the ingredients like you were about to or whatever,
but I read the effects.
Yeah.
Okay.
Got You.
Raise my immune system going to need that plane.
A bunch of dirty people.
Not all,
but many of you men sneezing,
sneezing on everyone,
coughing on everyone.
And,
and by the way,
cause I'm going to go talk to people.
I can't be going Jocko.
Yeah.
Can't do that.
I have to actually be able to talk.
Yeah.
Coffee and seen,
excuse me for the whole time.
It's awful.
If you,
if you sneeze or cough when you're on a mic in front of a big group of people,
not cool or if you keep doing it,
shroom till good shoot on it.com you know the good stuff's in the Elca.
Yes.
On it.com you want 10% off all this stuff on it.com/jocko and here's the thing
we just talked about right now.
We talked about Krill oil,
shroom tech,
sport from tech,
immune,
alphabet,
bro.
We could go on all night with this because of all the good stuff.
This is what I'm saying today.
I did.
You watched me actually while I have Alpha brand today and I was thinking you
took it but then when you want it,
not long story about something and I was sort of wondering,
maybe he didn't take his Alpha brain today.
Oh Ben.
Then when I wrapped it up you were like,
oh,
here's all that alphabet.
I didn't see it.
That statement made me think you are an alphabet today just cause you were able
to complete your whole deal right there.
I'm going to get it to you.
I'll put it back,
listen to echo story and then when it comes to the closure,
you go get some of that.
C eight could take lead.
Take my lead example.
You understand what I'm saying?
The so Alpha brain,
if you don't know,
cause we haven't talked about it as much as I feel like as far as its role in
our lives,
my life,
you know,
I'm speaking for myself.
Where you take,
it's neutral.
It's called nootropic.
It's basically brain food,
brain food supplements,
you know,
like to,
to make your brain,
you know what I'm going to come together to,
cause I've been taking mostly on it,
uh,
mostly Alpha brain in the past in the powder because it tastes good.
Yeah.
The peach and the spice spice.
I've been taking it in that more than a,
I'm going to go and I actually ran out of the pills.
The capsules.
Wait,
so you,
you'd prefer the capsules,
you're saying?
Well,
sometimes capsules a little bit more convenient,
right?
Yeah.
Like if I'm,
if I'm doing an event or I'm going to go on a podcast and I didn't,
I want to just be able to Bam,
it makes sense to me off of Brady in the,
in the brainy.
See by you're always in a hurry doing a bunch of stuff.
Probably mix it up a little.
You know,
like when you brew tea it's like,
I don't know,
it's all experience anyway.
Either way they're both the same deal and they're called nootropics proven by
the way.
I'm not just saying what feels good for me,
so you should take it.
I'm not just saying that now when you,
you say that.
Yeah.
But to me that means more to me than,
I dunno why,
but like when you say,
oh,
it's been double,
triple blind,
placebo ball ball ball control.
But
yeah,
I would rather have like someone that I know say,
Bro,
I'm telling you,
take this stuff like I did with Krill oil to you.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It was more important than reading a bunch of facts about it and that takes
someone that you know and they're saying,
look man,
give it a little crack.
Trust me on this one.
And I think most people have that in one way or another.
Not with everything,
but yeah,
like if you recommend a movie or something like that.
And then meanwhile I look at the review,
three reviews are like super good,
but then you're like,
eh,
it was junk because of this.
Because of that.
It's,
yeah.
Went right to the classic ninety's con.
It's said nineties comedy.
What kind of mood is Jocko in when I go to the nineties called,
that's just ridiculous.
That's just ridiculous.
But I like his own Wilson in that movie.
No,
the other one.
Oh Yeah,
sorry,
I'm picking Ben.
So like,
I like that Guy Owen Wilson.
He's funny.
I liked him because he comes across as very
truthful in the way he says.
Almost naive.
Yeah.
He's just like,
seems like a good dude.
Keep fog to hang out with,
but he's kind of got this air about them that's pretty Aramide.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's interesting nonetheless,
back to the elephant brain.
I think that when they prove it,
I think certain people,
certain types of mindsets or whatever kind of more gravitate towards that.
Like they're like,
okay,
that's cool that it worked for you.
But that could have been placebo.
That could have been this.
That could have been your mood that day or whatever.
If I'm going to commit to this,
I want some on some hard facts.
Some people,
well this all,
so boom,
you got the hard facts as well as a legitimate recommendation because I was
taking this even before you know,
the podcast and stuff,
so I was into it.
Nonetheless.
I'll brain.
That's a good one.
A bunch of other cool stuff.
If you're into protein powder,
the good clean protein powder on there.
All the workout stuff too.
By the way,
I got a bunch of kettle bells.
They're a primal bells legend belt,
the artistic one.
They're dope.
Look on my Instagram.
There's some on there.
Anyway,
that is a good way to support yourself,
help yourself maintain the workouts,
physical activity,
all that stuff.
Uh,
so you can be successful in that way.
I don't think there's any excuse anymore.
I for real,
don't.
Also good way to support really good way to support Amazon.
Click through when you go and get the book
conversations with Major Dick Winters,
go to the website to listed there and click through there.
Boom,
so basically it's to Amazon.
Click through you,
bite through Amazon,
Amazon,
click through you before you do your shopping.
Click through the website.
Amazon boom supports the podcast.
Small action,
big reaction because the click through only takes what?
30 seconds.
I think we've determined maximum really,
so you know Kim,
some leeway,
so we'll say three section second and then the reaction is massive support for
this podcast.
That's a good way.
Amazon,
click through through the website,
[inaudible] dot com or I think it's [inaudible] dot com as well,
but just good to Jocko podcast.com.
Click through before you do your Amazon shopping.
Also subscribe to the podcast on iTunes.
If you haven't already,
stitcher,
Google,
play all these other podcasting,
providing platforms also on Youtube.
If you don't mind the WII video version of this podcast,
go to youtube,
watch it there.
It's kind of cool and adds that other layer of experience.
Yeah.
Everyone seems to do that when there's a guest.
Cause they don't know who that person is.
They know what you look like.
They know what I look like most most.
Yeah.
Most people will,
if they're listening to the podcast,
eventually they know what you look like,
they know what I look like.
And so there's no reason sometimes,
although sometimes you can see like when certain subjects come up and there's
maybe some intensity in the podcast,
more people watch it.
But if it's a pretty mellow podcast and we're just talking about whatever we're
talking about,
maybe not everyone feels the need to go to youtube,
but when the guest comes on,
people want to see what that person looks like.
And there's usually some more animated interactions.
Yes,
true.
Yeah.
Big Time.
Yeah man.
So if you're into that you don't want,
it'd be cool if you made a little clip of when Tim Kennedy was on and I read a
question from the audience was something along the lines of,
I said,
you know,
hey,
they took away bayonet training boot camp and Tim Kenny just goes,
God damn it.
That's one of my favorite parts of ancient podcast ever.
We need,
in that case,
I would really appreciate it if you'd make that clip.
Even if it was like 12 seconds long.
Just the part.
Yeah,
just 12 seconds long.
It would be worth having on there because everyone should know that.
That's a travesty that they stopped doing data at courses.
Then army bootcamp,
you got it.
Some people,
if they don't hear this exact part that me kind of confused,
but hey,
I think they'll appreciate it.
I think so.
Oh,
they'll hear it.
They'll dig it fully,
but there's good animation.
Yeah,
no,
he's getting crazy,
which is fun and really in general,
just the youtube,
that's an added,
like I said,
in that added visual layer,
you know,
if you're down for it.
Sometimes people,
you know,
you put it on your tea,
it,
let's say in your Gra you know,
you're working out or you know,
it's on the TV.
It's kind of like you're in the conversation a little bit more.
It feels like it.
And also if people subscribe to the Youtube Channel,
then when they can sign up where if you make an excerpt right,
then they can get that.
Cause that's cool.
That's good thing is as much easier to share an excerpt from the podcast than it
is to share an audio.
I don't even know how to share an audio piece of a podcast.
How you know how to do that.
It probably can't be done.
Probably that's why we have the youtube.
So yeah,
go ahead.
Subscribe to that one.
And speaking of the knee,
you mentioned the excerpts.
Yeah.
You put some excerpts you can't,
you don't want to share or you anticipate that this person not gonna listen to
two and half hours of a podcast.
When you share it,
you just get the little lesson,
you know,
that you want to share and be like,
hey,
how did you approach college?
You know what,
everyone,
yeah,
that's a popular,
um,
because everybody that went to college already wishes they had that when they
went to college.
So when they,
you know,
when they encounter someone who's going to,
go to college,
their kids are nephew,
neighbor,
whatever,
boom.
They have some advice directly from Jocko.
Anyway,
so yeah,
you can,
you share that,
subscribe to the Youtube.
That's the point there.
Subscribe to the Youtube if you want.
And if you want to support and you know,
if you want,
you can sign up for a little alert.
When I upload something on there,
I got those alerts.
You can get out.
Pretty stoked when I see something coming through.
It's like a little present,
you know?
Yeah.
It's on youtube.
Good one.
Um,
also chuck was the store,
it's called Jocko store Jocko store.com.
You know,
if you want to tee shirts and whatnot,
discipline equals freedom.
The one that simply says get after it on the front.
That seemed to have gone over pretty well.
I'd say.
Well,
and also it seems worth noting that we now offer the victory MMA shirt to the
Jocko uniform that I wear all the time.
I wear it when I record the podcasts,
I wear it all the time.
We,
you know,
obviously because we have our gym.
Yeah.
We have a lot of tee shirts are Jim's name on it.
And so I wear that tee shirt a lot.
Yeah.
And I always have.
And then I didn't intentionally do it on the podcast in the beginning.
I just happened to be wearing it two or three times.
And then someone said,
is that the only shirt Jocko where's,
and at that point I said,
why?
Yes it is no man.
You're like the guy on the fly.
I remember the movie the fly and the Lady's like,
oh,
what was her,
I forget her name.
She's like,
Hey,
that you're only set of clothes or something like that.
And she sees in his closet that they're all the same.
Oh yeah.
That is me.
I like to have the things that are the same,
but people would come and ask me,
hey,
where can I get the teacher?
Where can I get the t shirt?
So now we put it on the Jocko store.
Strangely they didn't even have them at victory.
I know would come in and be like,
hey,
we want to the original score.
This is an original,
this is the original victory MMA tee shirt and we had to re produce it.
It's a reissue and all that,
which just opened its own respect,
right?
Yeah,
it is.
So I'm trying to think like is that enough?
It's not because it's the exact same design.
It's literally the exact same.
The same file,
right?
Yeah.
Boom.
So you didn't get that one if you want it.
Yeah,
you can represent present big time.
It's good.
It's interesting because yours are like old school,
so they kind of have like a fade to them.
You know,
you get the known,
they're like Whoa.
Leeming beaming.
I'm clean minute.
Grab a couple of those too,
by the way.
All right,
well just cause I was running low and I would hate to have other things in my,
what's that called when you have clothes I wardrobe.
Yeah.
Good thinking Jocko.
Anyway,
Jocko,
store.com check those out.
Some other new stuff,
stuff,
things,
items on there.
Let me talk about this mug.
I'm going to take too much time because we've been,
you know we've been going at it.
So this,
this travel mug right here.
So you know how you know at home,
you know you have your cup.
You see what I'm saying?
You know what I'm talking about?
It's the one I have actually my wife wants,
she searched forever to get me a cup that I like and she found it and then she
went to target and bought,
you know a does nothing.
There's big giant plastic,
but feel like glass,
whatever that is.
Acrylic or something can't break but you can,
but they,
they feel good in your hands.
So I have a bunch of those,
but apparently it's getting replaced.
Yes.
So strangely I had the same thing.
Well,
I was on the same search,
so I had this one.
What I arrived at,
my favorite cup was pink because they didn't have any other colors.
It was pink,
but it was big.
It was like maybe like 24 ounce,
like big cup.
That's what it used for.
Everything it pink,
whatever.
That meant.
Nothing compared to do their manhood.
Yemen competitive compared to the functionality of the pink was nothing.
Um,
but here's the thing,
he could barely fit in my cup holder.
You know the kind of like you put it in,
but it was like kind of stuck.
You'd have to fine.
But that was the cop.
That was the best one.
You use any other copy?
You just,
I dunno,
how are you doing now?
I'm going to get to that.
So,
but you know what I mean though,
so you know exactly what I mean.
Where you know,
you have your cup.
I don't,
where's my,
it could be dirty.
There can be cups every week.
All available.
You're like,
no,
I'm going to go and wash this,
you know,
and I'm going to use a cup.
That's it.
This one?
Okay,
we'll talk about this,
this mug.
It's a technically what it travel tumbler,
right.
Been hurting or whatever,
you know,
come to the top,
all that stuff.
But you take all the top boom,
that's a cup to ergonomically uh,
conducive to just using it as a Co.
You know Holly,
if you have like threads in there to screw on a top thread this thick.
Yeah,
it's like a thing anyway.
And that's not to mention the look black on black with a call it murdered out.
Ever heard that expression murdered out?
No trick.
Google,
if you have time,
Google murdered out Cadillac was tar what it is,
it's a flat matte.
Okay.
Painting with black wheels.
So it's like basically all black tinted.
Linda's all black.
So that's this thing is murdered out technically.
Um,
flat black matte with like the logo,
the four 34 and the discipline equals treatments like shiny black on black.
Very nice.
So,
and that's just the design.
So function wise,
perfect.
30 Ounces,
not 24 30,
straight up
and it,
what is it?
BPA free.
All of it.
So you don't get poisoned over time.
Come on Bro.
That's a big thing.
And also,
okay,
and here's the impressive part.
When I ultimately was like Dang,
like impressed.
I guess it's like a technology that's kind of been around but I didn't know
cause I had that Plastic Cup,
you know,
whatever this it'll keep,
it'll separate the temperatures from inside and outside so the inside
temperature won't leak to the outside.
Meaning it keeps like if you have ice and cold stuff in here,
bro means it's insulated.
It'll,
yeah,
but it's insulated in a special,
crazy way.
If you,
and this is with no top on by the way you fill it up with ixe your ice water,
you know,
this is what I did one time I finished like it was maybe three quarters of,
it's still some water in there and I just,
I kind of left it,
went to bed the next day I looked at it and the ice was still in there and yeah,
sure.
That doesn't mean that much.
But as far as proving how it keeps the temperature,
wow,
that's a lot straight up.
Also.
It doesn't like sweat.
You know how when you have a cold drink,
come on on a on it yet.
If it's on your desk isn't working.
Yeah,
screw some stuff up.
Hot Day,
whatever.
Humid.
It's like,
yeah,
it doesn't even do that.
It doesn't do that at all.
One time I was outside the pool,
whatever,
cruising I swabbed her.
Actually it was Jocko white tea.
Boom.
Oh well we'll get to that too,
but so you know I leave it there and it's in the sun and I grab it and I'm like,
ah,
this is going to be totally melted because I'm feeling it.
The the cup physically feeling the outside of the cup and it's straight up hot.
The Sun is beaming on it's hot.
If I look inside ice,
still the full on ice,
not even melted at all.
Well,
I'm telling you when they replaced her cup,
I'm telling you right now when you replace this cup,
you're going to find all these benefits to it above and beyond just the dope and
size and it fits in your cup holder straight up.
See how it's like the shape.
Cool.
All right,
next.
Next thing.
I feel like we could talk about this.
We're a little bit more,
I'm just like it.
I'm glad you liked it.
I like it too.
I'm utilizing it.
Actually.
I'm impressed my teeth.
I see us still icy rubbing,
getting down with this Cup mug for a long time.
Then thoroughly impressed.
Anyway,
so yeah,
we got some,
we got that on the jungle store,
Jacqueline,
store.com we've got it on there all.
So should we talk about the warrior kid shirts?
You can talk about that all right there on there to where your kids shirts,
youth sizes for your kids.
Boom.
There it is.
Very,
very cool for your kids out there.
There's some layers and now and two that I just found out by the way.
Your contribution,
the colors and whatnot.
Yeah.
Yes.
Don't worry about that book.
Check it out again.
[inaudible] dot com there's some rash guards on their new rash guards out.
Maybe they're out.
Hoodies.
What kind of getting into like a spring.
I mean maybe some are pretty soon,
so hoodies might not be as applicable.
Either way.
They're on there.
We need to start prepping the winter hoodies that I'm going to be more in charge
of this time to that they're heavier and more powerful.
Yeah.
Cause you're thinking New England winter.
I'm fan collide.
Chicago and Minnesota and Iowa.
I'm not thinking of Hawaii over here.
If wasn't quite what?
He wears a shirt,
sweatshirt.
That was my whole point.
You're like hoodies probably.
What is that?
Yeah.
You know what it was actually my wife knows what do these are,
so I just consulted with her nonetheless.
[inaudible] dot com that's some cool stuff on their travel mugs.
Shirts,
cool shirts support that way and you know you get a little,
I eat them.
Represent in the wild.
Boom.
Also support yourself with this one.
Psychological warfare.
If you didn't know what that is,
which I know you already do,
but if you don't,
it's an album with tracks.
No music jock on there.
And these tracks are useful.
These are utility.
What do you call them?
Functional tactical tracks to help you stay on the path.
You know,
we talked about getting distracted.
Some people they'll get distracted by comfort,
you know,
like the path.
The Path isn't code is riddled with discomfort riddled and sometimes after
awhile that that discomfort can get to certain people at certain times.
So what this psychological warfare album does is it keeps you on the path.
So for example,
you want to wake up every day early,
they that one day you're distracted by the comfort of hitting the snooze button,
getting 10 more,
20 more minutes of sleep.
That's bad.
That's a distraction.
That's a deviation from the path.
Listen to psychological warfare.
Uh,
what's the number?
Number one,
I think do it up and get after it.
Get up and get a listen to that.
Put it as your alarm.
I dare you to hit snooze.
Dare you.
Jock will just tell you practically in a practical,
pragmatic way why you should not hit the snooze.
Boom.
Um,
I would say with 100% certainty that you will not hit the snooze and you will
stay on the path.
And that goes for all these other things.
Deviating from diet,
deviating from pushing yourself in a workout,
deviating from going to the gym in the first place.
Going exactly right.
Or if you have like this procrastination situation,
man,
that's,
that's the main one that you don't like.
How you're always like,
hey,
I should I need to do this.
I should do this.
Just stop doing it.
Yeah,
procrastination is pretty much the thing that's going to keep you from doing it.
And then the last thing,
if you procrastinate this,
they got a little solution for you too.
Anyway,
psychological warfare,
Jocko Willink,
look for it on iTunes or Amazon music by the way.
It's a good one.
That's pretty cool.
Also,
while you're on Amazon,
you can get this book that we just covered today.
Conversations with major dick winters,
Jocko white tea is also available on Amazon.
If you don't want to drink sodas,
which no one should be drinking sodas at all,
you don't need them.
They're there actually horrible for you.
But remember when we were eating Sushi in New York and a busted
out the coke I was,
I was going to actually just,
I was surprised.
I thought that you weren't going to be my friend anymore,
but like real,
I couldn't believe it.
So anyways,
echo has this tradition,
which to me sounds like a sugar coated.
The lie then when he eats Sushi has bought glass bottle of coke so that um,
I overcame my hatred for him the best I could.
It's Kinda like when I was talking today about like,
Hey,
if you're a vet,
you can't look at everyone.
Like,
Hey,
this person I had to be,
I had to be like,
okay that goes not a bad person.
It's just mentally weak right now.
We'll just deal with it.
Don't drink that drink Jocko white tea,
which actually tastes better than coke.
There's no doubt.
But it tastes better than coke.
That's subjective.
But sure.
Are you serious right now?
I'm saying better as a subject then everyone agrees with in the world.
Put It side by side.
Taste test.
There you go.
We'll go.
Boom.
Guarantee everybody cares.
Gimme that gimme that gimme the Jocko white tea,
they don't want that.
It's syrup.
Sugar.
I think you might be 147% correct.
Absolutely.
We'll do a taste test only you can taste the coke cause I'm not,
I'm not touching my lips to that stuff.
Nasty.
One time they had a wheat,
we have a PT situation,
we call it a monster mash.
Sure.
And it's you just do a bunch of crazy events or pull ups and rope climbs and
carry boats around and swim.
And we were doing it when I was,
uh,
the officer in charge of trade debt.
And so yeah.
Oh,
I see a trade it.
So I brought my son with me and they had did this monster mash and one of the
things you had to do in the monster mash and this thing is being timed in
surveys and all that stuff.
You had to drink a full coca cola through a straw.
My son's doing the monster mash and he's probably seven or something like that.
And he'd never even had a coke before we burned his mouth probably.
Yeah.
And he,
he just hated it.
It was so nasty to him.
Yeah,
that's how I looked at you the other day.
I was like,
dude,
you're making me sick.
So Jocko white tea,
you know,
go on there,
read the reviews as well.
You know,
you'll see things like this excellent to you.
When I need to crush and power through the work,
I brought me some Jocko white tea.
If I need a little extra kick to crush it,
that's what I do.
I'd be going working fewer hours at the office as my productivity has risen 900%
that's pretty legit numbers.
Yeah.
And obviously that's 100% accurate because it came from an Amazon review.
So and,
and actually there's a warning as well.
Caution regarding this product.
Leaving your supply of Jocko white tea out in the open will require Overwatch.
I now have non tea drinkers hitting my reserves almost as badly as dedicated tea
drinkers.
No double blind study required.
Right.
That's,
this is the thing.
It doesn't taste like tea,
right?
It doesn't like tea in my opinion.
It tastes like it tastes like victory,
but it doesn't taste like to you.
So that's that Jocko white tea,
you can get it on amazon.com way the warrior kid,
the book is out as you know.
Thank you for getting it.
Kids have been crushing it.
It's awesome.
That's one of my favorite things that has happened to me in the past several
years is people started posting pictures of their kids reading way.
The warrior kid.
Yeah.
And that was awesome for me to see and I'll tell you why it was awesome.
Cause I know,
I know those kids are reading that book and they're thinking that they're going
to get a little bit better and a little bit stronger and a little bit faster and
a little bit smarter and they're going to,
and people are sending me pictures of kids doing pushups and kids doing,
a guy sent me
a video of his kid.
You know how you have little uh,
night vision in your kid's room too?
You can monitor them.
Oh like on the little monitor,
a little monitor thing who sent me a picture,
a video of the Monitor,
the kids in the room after nighttime,
after bedtime with the kids doing it.
Plus you up.
He's doing pushups.
Why?
He wants to get stronger,
wants to get better.
So yeah,
you get that.
If you've got kids,
get it from.
If you're an adult,
that's cool.
Get it.
Anyways.
I'll,
adults have a lot to learn from uncle Jake,
myself included,
so run out,
go to your local bookstore
and grab copies.
If they don't have it in your local bookstore,
tell them to get it so that other kids can see it and get it.
Let's make people better.
Also,
you can preorder discipline equals freedom field manual.
Again,
you can find it in the get after it section of any bookstore or online
bookseller.
It is the only book in that section.
If your bookstore doesn't have that section,
which it probably won't tell them to get after it and make one and then put
discipline equals freedom there and get a copy of it for yourself.
Extreme ownership.
Yes.
The fundamental principles of combat leadership,
they will help you win in any capacity on the battlefield.
On the beat in business in life.
Yeah.
Extreme ownership written by myself and my brother Leif Babin.
You can get that book as well if you need more than the podcast and the book,
that's fine.
It's okay.
Contact or the leadership and management consulting,
consulting company,
Echelon Front info@echelonfront.com.
Now the monster,
the monster,
we just got done with musters zero zero two in New York City.
What's your assessment?
Echo Charles.
My assessment was that it,
it was an upgrade.
It is.
It was an upgrade from the first one in that scene a lot because at first one
was good.
I was like,
Dang,
that was really impactful to the kind of where,
and I don't really say,
well this event was
impactful.
I don't use that word.
Not because I'm above it or nothing like that,
but I'm just saying to say it,
it gotta be frugal.
So that first one was Dallas,
like Dang this,
this is really good
from top to bottom.
Like even k,
the material booms,
like all usable material,
all of it.
And then like always saying,
I think people overlook this part a lot of time,
like just the social element.
It's so easy to make friends with everyone because they all kind of have the
same kind of interesting goals in one way or another.
There's going to be some overlap there.
And then she just took part was fun too.
You know,
it's like it's just this great event,
you know?
And then the second one,
and I wasn't,
I'm be honest with you,
I wasn't as fired up cause it was in New York.
It's like outside of the comfort zone,
the first one here,
San Diego,
I was like,
oh sweet this like it was even better.
That's that this past one was better.
It was getting great feedback.
Awesome.
And like you said,
I think the important,
well one of the most important things that you just said is it's very pragmatic.
It's not like,
it's not like,
hey,
you're going to learn some stuff but it's not going to be really applicable.
No,
no,
no.
It's going to be applicable.
And you walk out when you finish that section and we get done talking about it,
boom.
You can,
you can implement that immediately.
Yeah.
It's interesting,
you guys have like a lot of military stories and examples,
you know,
and then,
but when you go to the Q and a,
like all the people with their questions and not one of them is military.
It's all work.
Maybe relationship may be here and there,
but it's like at work you don't like,
what do I do?
And exactly.
And every one of those situations we answered them.
I'd say we answered them with both business examples that we've experienced and
military examples.
But yeah,
you,
you absolutely.
We've seen,
this is the thing we've seen it happened before.
Whatever that little issue is that you've,
you're having seen it before.
You know,
I've seen it before.
I've seen something like it will be able to find an answer,
come to a conclusion and move forward with the techniques,
the principles that we talk about extreme ownership.
But it's like this extreme ownership.
The book is an awesome way to get the fundamental principles,
but when you come to the event now,
you can really personalize it.
You know,
you can really make sense of it.
It's just like learning Jujitsu.
Like it's cool.
Yeah.
Watch the youtube videos.
Also go to class.
Also go to the seminar,
learn it from as many different angles as you can because the more angles you
learn it from the battle you,
the more proficient you'll be at applying them to your world.
Yeah.
And the,
yeah,
and that's not,
you know,
you talk about Jujitsu,
another cool part about it is,
you know,
when we teach the Jujitsu in the last day,
like you can come and actually like well try to choke Jocko,
come and bring it.
You think that's going to cause,
think about it most times like if you go to like a,
you know,
oh yeah,
you can't go try to choke the guy at the end of it.
You know,
you can't say like,
um,
Hey,
I'm going to go see this concert and then afterwards I'm going to pick up a
guitar.
Him Play,
you know the Solos with Eric Clapton.
Yeah,
exactly.
Right.
That doesn't happen.
And that's through camp.
Yeah.
And this is like,
like actually choking up the person,
you know.
So that's like an added element,
I mean,
I got to roll with that.
Plenty of the guys,
man.
It's just so cool to be like,
oh yeah,
you know,
we talk and we talk about this and then get it off afterwards,
you know?
And so anyways,
if you didn't make it to New York City,
which was Awesome Times Square,
we had a great time.
The next one,
we're having July 13th and 14th in Austin,
Texas,
the Omni Barton creek resort and spa.
Now this is one thing that it just is what it is.
In New York,
we,
we were planning to do like 350 people and then we sold that out.
We opened it up for another 50 and we and we,
and we had to expand our room to get that and then that sold out.
And so then we,
we rearranged the,
or the,
the situation in there to get more people in there.
It looks like an Austin.
We're capped.
We can't get any bigger than the room that we've got.
And so it's three 50 so if you want to come sign up quick before it gets sold
out cause there's no way we can expand it into more people.
So just be aware of that.
If you can't make that for 13th and 14th of July 13th and 14th in Austin,
Texas,
San Diego,
California,
September 14th and 15th we're back in San Diego for follow on operations.
So come and get it
while you're waiting for the monster.
If you need to pass communications to myself or Echo Charles,
we can be found on the interwebs.
Twitter,
Instagram plus.
Well Ah,
we ah,
that Facebooky echo is at Echo Charles and I am at Jocko Willink
and thanks to everyone for listening to the podcast for sharing the podcast for
supporting the podcast.
We really do appreciate it.
Thanks to military personnel out there that are protecting our freedoms overseas
and also the law enforcement,
the firefighters,
EMT first responders that keep us safe here at home.
Thanks to you all
and
to everyone.
Yeah,
whatever your mission might be.
Let's think about Dick Winters.
Personal quest,
very simple to excel in everything.
He did
excel in everything he did.
We should do the same excel in everything we do
from working to working out,
from the way we treat people.
Okay.
To the way we treat ourselves.
Excel
put forth your effort in everything you do from a small,
seemingly meaningless tasks to the big goals.
Okay.
As you attack those goals,
or as those goals start to grind you down,
remember the obsessive,
pure,
determined effort
that Dick winters taught us all.
Yeah.
And go out there,
then get after it.
So until next time,
this is echo and Jocko
out.